at the End of
Time 13
O
can you hear me yeah now can you hear me
S check sound check now can you hear me
hello hello hello hello can you hear
me can anybody hear me testing testing
yeah it should be on now
okay should be on now right yeah okay
okay I don't
know I swear to God this stuff does just
weird [__] on its own because Not only
was the ring light up at maximum
brightness even though I didn't touch it
um I moved it oh maybe that's what it
was okay well that explains that but
this doesn't yeah but that doesn't
explain that's right yeah that's right
we took we took it in the other room but
that doesn't explain why in OBS this
turned the microphone off like the
microphone itself is on but in OBS it
said no device connected so okay
whatever but um no all we were saying
when we we were muted was that it seemed
like it was just Thanksgiving like a
couple weeks ago and now it's already
Thanksgiving again next week which is
crazy the older you get man the faster
years go by I know it's kind of
depressing yeah you get into your 40s
and 50s and [__] they go by so fast like
oh [__] it I'm already
dead I got nothing to
lose well don't don't look at it that
way I don't care I'm just [__] going
I don't care I don't care I don't care
time the it happens when it happens yeah
yeah you can't worry about it too much
probably like you probably die faster
worrying about it yeah I'm having fun
than you would otherwise I'm having fun
yeah well that's good I'm having fun
long you're still having fun yeah still
looking good it's all coming together
good yeah yeah I can still do everything
I need want to do yeah yeah see that's
always good yep that's always good all
right so we're doing another True Crime
show uh you know we did um serial killer
last week we're also doing a serial
killer this week but the difference here
uh well a couple differences differences
here is that this uh serial killer
unfortunately is also a PDF file and uh
you know so went after kids and this one
has not been caught and now it might be
more than one person they're not
entirely sure which we'll get into a
little bit later because this one might
be involved in like a whole PDF file
ring uh so we'll kind of get into that
as the time goes on I feel like this is
a case and this happened in your old
stomping grounds of
Michigan uh a little bit north of
Detroit Oakland County do you know where
that is uh I I remember the name I've
never been up there it's like north of
Detroit I think it's kind of a more
affluent area it might still be I don't
know and it definitely was at this time
but um that's where all of them happened
this happened back in the
1970s so yeah you it's weird because you
don't really hear a lot about this case
anymore um even though at the time that
it happened I think it was like the
biggest murder investigation like in the
United States ever you know what I'm
saying yeah but it just seemed like even
though they never caught the person or
persons responsible you don't really
hear much about it yeah grur said
Oakland county is the most affluent
County in Michigan yeah I thought it was
yeah because I definitely um I was
watching the documentaries about it and
they did mention that it had that it was
in the 70s and I assumed it still was
but I wasn't entirely sure so I guess it
is I guess it is Sebastian saying that
there are good Mammoth Mountain
Poltergeist interviews on Spotify I
don't know which ones he's talking he
says it's us yeah we we did like a lot
of shows about that when the book came
out over time yeah I don't some of them
were for radio I kind of did one for
NPR um some of them were from podcast so
I don't know exactly the ones you're
talking about uh some of them have just
Jen some of them have both us both of us
on it yeah couple of them I think just
have me yeah
yeah yes so I don't know that was a long
time
ago yeah it was it's been a while
yeah gther says the Oakland County
killer was the son of a GM executive
yeah we'll get into uh we'll get into
that that's one of the possibilities for
sure uh an he also says this case still
makes the news in Michigan every now and
then lots of Auto execs live in Oakland
County yeah Tammy saying that uh she's
going to live to 100 and she said
great-grandfather and my and my
grandmother both live to be 101 years
old yeah my mother's side of the family
they're just they're
Immortal her parents just died and all
her sisters are still alive yeah her
oldest one is her oldest sister is still
alive yeah uh but I think my
grandparents on that side of the family
they died in their mid
90s so they live forever yeah and have a
lot of they have high blood pressure too
it doesn't matter it doesn't kill us
mine's slightly high but that's just
normal for our family you could have 140
over something that just what it's going
to be mine's like unnaturally low yeah
and always has been so a dad side of the
family they didn't live long it's all
about they didn't live as long my
granddad on my dad's side he died at I
think late 40s of a heart attack
fighting he was rooting over two guys
fighting on television died of hard it
was a boxing match right boxing match
yeah yeah and he died of a hard well
like I said at least he died he must
have had some kind of congenital heart
defect something it it had to been
something like that probably back in
those days they didn't never was
Mississippi they didn't do autopsies
just yeah he
died he died of something it's hard well
they don't usually do an autopsy unless
they unless the death is suspicious they
wouldn't normally no he was just laying
in front of the television set yeah he
said his he said his uh he said he
didn't feel good he was cheering he goes
man I don't feel good and my grandmother
says you want me to get you something to
drink he goes yeah get uh give me some
give me he said give me some sweet tea
and he sat down in sat back down in the
chair and he [__] boom bowled over
when she came back he was on FL dead
that's crazy yeah I mean at least it was
quick I guess he probably didn't know
what happened to him he was yelling and
screaming over the damn fight well don't
get that excited about the boxing match
that's the lesson there grur says other
Michigan serial killers the ipsilanti
killer yeah I think we did a show about
him not too long ago and Coral Watts we
might have done did we do a show about
Coral Watts I feel like s famili gay guy
was killing all the male prop feel like
maybe we did oh co okay I for a second I
got him confused used with uh that other
heinous [__] that was sticking
them [__] glass rods up in them
boys's dicks um yeah what was that um
Dean Coral Dean coral Coral Dean Coral
yeah the candy man yeah and he buried
him all he buried them all in the damn
storage container and the grounded at a
[__] there's a lot of
[__] [__] out there in the
world yeah he had that young guy as an
accomplice that was bringing him to
victims paying him for it and that was
the kid that eventually killed him for
getting ready to torture a girl to death
that was a good story we did we did the
show on that yeah yeah that was pretty
that was yeah it was pretty messed up I
have [__] that dude up man I mean and he
was ex Army guy yeah yeah Tammy said my
daughter looked into the into whoops it
just moved looked into the family of my
great-grandfather had a sister lived to
be
107 holy crap that's uh that's old I've
never really heard about anybody living
that long other than like you know in
the Guinness Book of World Records and
stuff yeah gther said Coral Watts killed
80 to 100 women in Michigan and Texas if
we didn't do a show on him then we need
to at some
point uh also murder Hornet said do one
on Paul Reed I was in prison with him
the fast food killer yeah I think he's
on my list somewhere we just haven't got
around to doing him yet you know we'll
get around to him that's the thing it's
just like there's so many serial killers
and it's like like I said I write about
serial killers all the time but it's
like I'm always coming across new
ones yeah michigans a weird weird place
me and grter GRS grew up there he's
still there um I did like two years
there in in high school in between going
to back and forth to Brazil for high
school um my stepdad was from there
that's that's how I ended up
there Michigan's pretty but it's also
kind of like the United States's version
of [__] Siberia that's got a real
cold winter and that's where they were
making all the tanks during World World
War II it was like torad you know was in
Siberia um it was an industrial
Powerhouse for a while but then it just
tore itself apart over time um Place had
real pretty girls they were Scandinavian
and Czech or not C Czechoslovakian
mixure of Scandinavian girls and Slavic
Girls lived were from up there we went
to high school with them me and grandpar
went to drama school there
together and uh cute girls yeah and then
s sofa comes down and visit she's from
there she got that they all look like
swed like they're from
Sweden big tall girls yeah yeah big old
feet
man they all size 11 and [__] is that
they all have big old feet no but
they're tall they got big old
feet well they they came in all sizes
you know but yeah I'm pretty that's kind
of like you could tell who was who you
could tell the ethnic background that's
all they were yeah grur said Trenton
girls knew how to treat a boy oh yes
they did take them down the damn drivein
and [__] Steve's Love Palace Steve's
Love Palace oh my God the love dungeon
Tom loves talking about that yeah that's
fun relive in Your Glory Days that was
my Glory Days it got better got better
as it
went that was just the Genesis that was
the Genesis of the dialect origin Tom's
origin yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah in Doctor Who terms that was
the Genesis of the dialect so is where I
came from it yeah okay all right so uh
okay so got a couple of housekeeping
things we need to do obviously before we
get into the show and the first thing
that we do if you've been here for the
last couple of weeks you know that we
now have some uh affiliate uh stuff
going on so we're going to talk today
about one of our Affiliates which is
audible you know what that is Audible is
Amazon's offshoot they do uh audiobooks
and podcasts and all that other kind of
stuff and uh all of my books almost all
of my books I think are available on
Audible and it's me reading them all my
true crime books my paranormal books all
my horror novels my short story
collections all that kind of stuff uh
you can go on there and listen to those
if you want to and if you click the
little link down in the description box
you will get a 30-day free trial of
audible
uh you can listen to anything in their
catalog without needing any credits you
also get uh one credit which you can use
on anything you want and you can keep
that forever if you're already an Amazon
Prime member then you actually get two
credits that you can spend and you can
keep that forever also so again full
disclosure if you click on the link in
the description box we do get a
commission from that but yeah so thanks
to Audible for being our affiliate uh
it's really awesome so yeah ALS so
here's something and I had been thinking
about this and Tom had this idea
also and you guys know that I
occasionally when I have time to do it
will put up movie reviews or book
reviews I haven't done any book reviews
lately because I just haven't had time
to like finish reading a book like I'm
in the middle of two different books and
I just haven't had time to finish them
but because it's quicker to do movie
reviews because I can sit and watch a
movie in an hour and a half and then you
know write our script and do the video
and everything but Tom said you should
well that I should do the my movie and
book reviews My flickers of fear TOS of
Terror like that I should do them as
live
streams and I don't know I do kind of
like that idea I don't know if I'd ever
be able to do them like regularly but I
could maybe do like one a week or two a
week or something like that where I
could just jump on I don't know if I'd
ever have like a set time because it
would just be whenever I had time to do
them that's the good thing about it but
yeah so so we might be able to get
listeners that don't ever get to see us
live or anything like that and I don't
usually stream
solo um but it might be worth doing uh
again it would probably save me some
time so because I wouldn't have to edit
the videos which would be nice but uh
because that is kind of time you'll run
you'll run into uh fans of all the
different shows that we have at random
times they're in different time zones
yeah you'll be able to interact with
them you'll get super chats and stuff
because Tom was noticing especially on
Instagram that a lot of people that
comment um or that like my posts about
my book reviews are are not
necessarily um people that would comment
on the Regular Show yeah it's two
different crowds so it's slightly like
I'm there's overlap obviously but um
there does seem to be like particularly
my book reviews because you know like on
Instagram and YouTube and stuff there's
like a whole Community mhm of uh people
that are into like horror books and
stuff and uh you know she got like I I
like um jordal line like she's pretty
cool and uh shades of orange she's
another one that does like horror and
Thriller and stuff and I like her but
there's a lot of really good ones so I
that's something that I'm probably going
to consider like maybe starting in a
week or two um maybe doing the stuff as
live streams if you guys would like
would like that I mean obviously you can
still watch them later if you don't
catch them live because like I said I
don't think I could ever do a schedule
like oh this day at this time I'm going
to live stream because I never know if
I'm G to have time to do it but and if
you uh if you're catching if you're
catching um this
show uh you know the like the uh
paranormal and the uh True Crime shows
if you're catching these recorded
because you're in another time zone you
now have another chance where you could
actually interact live with Jen yeah so
you can actually ask questions about
this show too she doesn't care you just
you can ask her any questions about any
show she does yeah and she'll be able to
interact yeah I'm pry you know what you
know what I'm like I'm pretty I think
you're going get a lot of like fans also
from your book reviews yeah you'll be
able to do with I need to really do some
more books I'm still I'm still reading
SLE foot by Braum which is really good
but I just haven't had time to like get
through it I'm only probably about a
quarter of the way through it yeah I
mean what sometimes I do if I'm you know
and I have a book and I don't have time
and it's like man I really need to get a
book review up is I'll go on um because
I have Kindle unlimited that a
subscription to that so you can go on
and there's like ebooks and you can read
them for free so I'll just find like a
novela or something that I can read in
like a couple of hours and then like
just review that because SLE foot is
kind of long and I kind of want to I
bought the a print version of that so I
kind of want to like saor it you know
what I mean it's kind of like the witch
I'm going to say like if you liked the
witch um you would probably really like
slooh foot at least so far I don't know
what's going to happen in it because I'm
only about a quarter of the way through
but yeah so I'm kind of just considering
that I think that might be a good thing
to do like I said might you can find the
live stream in its proper place inside
the playlist right yeah I always put
yeah cuz I have playlists for everything
cuz you know how anal retentive I am
about like classifying everything got to
be classified so people had to know like
you know I have a thing how I have the
channel laid out it's like I have all
the videos at the top but then like I
have the playlist like all book reviews
all movie reviews you know so I just
kind of put everything in there you know
what I mean uh Tammy says just read us
the book live bedtime reading with
Jen yeah I could maybe do that I could
maybe do that but yeah I think that
probably would be more fun and I would
probably do it more in like the
afternoons you know because that's
usually when I would have time to do it
so afternoon in our time zone yeah yeah
yeah Eastern Standard Time so it'd
probably be I don't know it' probably be
like two or three in the afternoon or
something like that probably uh murder
Hornet said I like Jen's other channel
well thank you I need to I need to post
something over on scar Salon too because
I just put something on the crime
channel uh scar Salon still needs I
think it still needs 100 subscribers
before it can be monetized um and I'm
kind of pushing for that I'm working on
a scare Salon video although I might
post it on this channel honestly I'm
doing a history of horror but like I
said it's taking forever yeah if you
haven't subscribed to scar Salon go over
there
and make that make that 100 more I do
kind of like longer form stuff over
there like I've been I'm doing like some
series I'm doing a series called um my
five favorite horror movies from every
year since I was born so I'm up to 1982
now I think that's going to be the next
one that I'm going to put up um I'm also
going through the Boris carof show
Thriller from 19 1960 and 1961 so I'm
going through episodes of that and I'm
also doing Night Gallery so I'm kind of
like going through I occasionally post
other like long form reviews like
sometimes I'll do um like a comparison
of a movie In A Book Like I think I did
one on burnt offerings and I think I did
one
on uh no one gets out alive I think I
did one on the house next door I don't
know but I sometimes I do that too but
it's just kind of like whatever I like I
said I do longer form stuff over there
and it's just kind of like random what
whatever I think of said he just
subscribed to it okay thank you yeah I'm
trying to get up to a thousand so I can
get it monetized but the CME the crime
one is monetized um but the scar Salon
is the only one that isn't and I haven't
posted anything on there for a few weeks
because I just haven't had time and the
history one I'll probably I was going to
try to get it up for Halloween but
obviously that didn't happen because
like I said it was a lot more work than
I uh anticipated so I'm maybe going to
try and get it up for Christmas like cuz
I wanted to do it like as a big special
thing but but I might put that on this
channel well I don't know we'll see
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens so I think that's kind of all
the stuff we had to talk about right
yeah let me get I'll put get some more
ice let me get that uh yeah cuz look at
look at how that ice is I put ice in
there somebody said um where was it I
just saw somebody that was in oh Jeffy
art said just finished class now I'm
leaving Miami soaking wet how's the
weather in Orlando it has been it hasn't
been raining raining but it's been like
cloudy here for like 3 days which I
don't mind at all but it's been kind of
raining off and on but it's been like
real real overcast kind of like Breezy
which I like I said I kind of like it
but Tom is bummed out cu he can't like
ride his motorcycle you know what I mean
because he's afraid it's going to rain
so I think it rained on Monday afternoon
but not hard but it was just kind of
like sprinkling rain but it's yeah it's
been real overcast but not pouring down
rain like I said I don't mind that cuz I
don't really like the brights on or
anything you know and let me see
what yeah Danny ring said I'm jonesing
for the Horror history episode yeah it's
just like I'm really I'm really excited
I'm having a good time like going
through and like WR because I'm writing
this massive
dissertation on it so that it's the
video is probably going to be like four
hours long we'll see how it go she been
so busy lately we we haven't even had
time to do stream yeah I mean we haven't
even done streammate for a few weeks
because it's we just haven't had time
too busy to do it like I've had a bunch
of freelance work we've had like a bunch
of other [__] going on I've had job
interviews we've had he's had VA [__]
like we've you know so we've had like
motorcycle stuff motorcycle [__] that he
had to fix and all this other kind of
stuff so we've kind of run out of time
of doing stuff but yeah and I still
haven't gone out shooting man I got to
take my [__] out I got I got a couple of
[__] AR-15 uppers I need to zero that
I built yeah and there's a new Range
local range it I'm going to take you you
want to go uh sure you cuz you haven't
shot anything yet no okay I'm she hasn't
really shot you haven't really shot
heavy a long time ago my dad took me
when I was younger when I was a shoot
straight it's an indoor range before we
moved here I haven't shot in over a
year and uh just went on my
own
yeah she was always at work yeah I mean
I'm always working yeah that's kind of
the thing
and I saw something else real quick that
I needed to oh Camp guy said the live
Vibe is what brings me yeah and honestly
the more I do this the more I kind of
like live streaming you know what I mean
I used to get real stressed out about it
but now I get more stressed out about
the recording stuff which is dumb
because you can just like if you [__] up
you can just fix it but honestly like
when I had kind of been thinking about
it in the back of my mind but then Tom
said why don't you live stream your
reviews it's like a lot of people watch
them and people seem to like those and I
was just kind of like yeah maybe I will
and then I can just go on in the
afternoon like for a little while and
talk about whatever horror movie I just
watched or some [__] like that I got a
message the other day that people really
liked that I talked about ones that were
like
forgotten and I said well there's a lot
to be said yeah for and you know
occasionally I will cover ones that are
real Buzzy like in the horror Community
you know like I did um a wounded Fawn
cuz a lot of people were talking about
that one and skar because a lot of
people were talking about that one but I
had wanted to see those anyway I don't
really like doing reviews of movies that
everybody else is doing just because
everyone else is doing them like I have
to really want to see it personally
otherwise I'm not going to bother and
honestly if I'm going to I would rather
watch something that was kind of off the
beaten path like I I really like to look
up like forgotten gems like from the 70s
and ' 80s and I really like to kind of
do deep Dives on that kind of stuff cuz
I like to find ones that not a lot of
people are talking about which is
probably not the best business decision
but you know I I don't know I just like
to do that cuz I feel like it's kind of
a niche and I do get messages that
people appreciate that instead of just
covering the same [__] that everyone
else is covering then we respond to
murder Hornet he's talking about the VA
we're both VA guys CRA you know if you
ever SE the movie
VFW or what was it Predator the new
Predator with the crazy VF VFW guys yeah
we're like that the crazy BFW guys
anyway or VA guys anyway he says the VA
sucks now yeah it does it [__] sucks
it doesn't work I you got to do all your
own [__] they tell you to make an
appointment with radiologist and stuff
and they want you to take to to keep
track of all the dates and get back they
don't talk to each other
anymore so to get to get appointments
done to tell your doctor VA the VA is
nonfunctional it's falling apart
although I always had private insurance
and they always make you do that too
they don't keep track of [__] yeah but
it used to be no they would make all the
appointments for you right like I'm
going to send you to the radi just I'll
make an appointment with them and then
you get it in the mail report here at
this date to get your [__] x-ray or
whatever no they they make you call them
now and set the date man I can't
remember what date I was supposed to set
that for Tom doesn't remember [__]
no no [__] I don't remember numbers
too well I'm really bad with dates J
will tell you that time I have no
concept of time no absolutely not nope
he has no idea what time it is is yep he
has no idea what day it is
yeah and I don't I can't tell I can't
tell the difference between two hours
and like six hours it's about the same
to me it feels about the same yeah
that's why I always have to go in and
like remind him like what time it is all
the time yep it's like hey time to do
the show yep I feel like a nag like
having to go in there and like say every
time but but he does he always forgets
if you were to ask me what day it was
I'd be like uh I'd have to think about
it might say I don't know
uh I don't know most of the time I
couldn't tell you what the date was I
mostly couldn't tell you I usually a lot
of times I can't tell you what month it
is I usually have to look up what Daye
it is what the date is you know what I
mean
so Danny Rowling said Tom's the dyslexic
Count from Sesame Street yeah yeah head
injuries it'll do that head inj head
head injuries will [__] up your sets of
time yeah you don't care about time
anymore yeah you're just all in a in a
constant state of now yeah it's just
right
now that's pretty much that's pretty
much Tom's World we're all it's just all
like like a animal like right now yeah
yeah it's it's all the present moment
yeah he's not worried about the future
or well no you you are kind of you I
know about the future you think about
the past a lot too yeah yeah but I kind
of feel like yeah all right so are we
ready to get into this extremely
depressing looks like we got a lot of
people in here now is ready to go I say
a lot of people's 25 people well that's
a lot for us that's that's that's a lot
for this show like I said we're like The
Velvet Underground of YouTube shows like
only the cool people listen to us but
nobody else does yeah they listen to us
recorded over
time you know what yeah Zach says so Tom
is experiencing The Spectacular Now yeah
he is actually yeah there the mego says
the same thing you got to call them more
than once to get anything sorted yeah
they're [__] up now yeah EA is [__]
up yeah they don't know what they're
doing anything that has all of that kind
of uh it used to work like a well oiled
machine I just think the machine's
falling apart that's what I think if the
va's falling apart that means everything
else is falling apart I know the Army is
[__] up there's there's no Army there
the public hasn't realized it but no as
far as from everything I've heard and
this is at the Pentagon level too
there's also no
generals every General they have is
doing another job and they have no
military backgrounds so there's no
generals it's just a big jobs
program Dan ring said what's tonight's
killer's name well that's the thing
nobody knows because this case is
unsolved they don't know who this [__]
is um and it could be more than one
person it might be more than one person
I kind of suspect it might be I don't I
don't know if it was more than one
person that did the canonical four
victims but there were probably more
victims which like I said we'll get into
in a little bit um all right so this
killer who we don't know who it is known
as the Oakland County child killer
sometimes known as the babysitter or the
babysitter killer as well which doesn't
make a lot of sense to me but okay
that's so they never called the CAU this
guy no okay they have not he at large he
is at large uh hopefully he's dead but
um they do have some suspects which
we'll get into in a bit uh some of the
suspects are dead some of them are
already in prison but you know like I
said we'll get into that they don't
really know exactly
who this might be so the canonical for
victims happened between it's about a
period of a year uh between
1976 and 1977 all of them took place in
Oakland County Michigan which is kind of
an affluent area north of
Detroit um things the victims all had in
common now there were a lot of
differences too which we'll get into in
a bit but um the similarities were uh
the victims were all held captive before
being killed for various periods of time
um also um where so I lost my place for
a second lost my place for a
second um they had like some
DNA um that has kind of implicated two
suspects indirectly um as I said one of
whom is dead uh the other is in prison
for something else um but the matching
matching DNA that they have that they
created the DNA profile of the
perpetrator from uh you know samples on
the victims doesn't match anybody that
they know of yet so the victims in this
case it was actually two little girls
and two little boys um all of them aged
between 10 and 12 years old all of them
disappeared while they were going uh
from their house to another location
usually like to a store or something
like that or were coming home from a
store something
um they were all last seen within a mile
of Woodward Avenue in Oakland County um
all of them as I said had been held
captive for a time all of them were fed
and taken care of their bodies were
washed their clothes were washed um and
they were
redressed um you know so they were all
bathed and everything all of the victims
had dog hair on their bodies from the
same white dog that's how they knew that
those four were related even though the
methods of murder were different uh in
several of the cases so but those but
there were a lot of differences too like
I said which we'll get into uh in a bit
what ages were they 10 to 12 okay um
also another thing that they had in
common all of the kids' bodies were
discovered in a very public area um
obviously the killer wanted them found
uh within 19 days of them uh
disappearing boys and girls yeah um the
kids were either strangled smothered or
shot uh the two boys were sexually
assaulted the two girls were
not um the bodies like I said were
usually dumped in very public areas
usually where they could be seen from a
major road so that obviously the killer
wanted them to be found as I said the
investigation here was at the time the
largest murder in investigation in US
history which is kind of um odd
considering that a lot of people don't
talk about this case that much anymore
four that they know of how many of those
were shot two of them were shot I
believe do you know where or wait no one
of them was shot well I'll get yeah just
I'm already profiled well yeah but let
me let me talk about stuff before you
jump to conclusions because I know how
you do you try to figure everything out
before I've told you anything okay I'm
Computing that [__] man Computing it
right but I haven't told you trying to
put this [__] together I haven't
told you anything yet okay I know that
well just victimology I haven't told you
just victimology tells me some stuff
just studying who the victims are
knowing how died it helps
okay okay so the first victim and these
are the four confirmed victims like I
said there were several that are
possible possibly related to the series
which I'll get into like at the end
after we talk about suspects and stuff
like that but the first of the canonical
four victims was named Mark steans and
he was 12 years
old so on the day after Valentine's Day
February 15th 1976 it was about 1:30 in
the afternoon and he talked to his mom
on the phone now he was at the American
Legion Hall I think he you know
volunteered there or something like that
and um he called her and said that he
was heading home he was going back to
the house and it wasn't far it was only
like a few blocks or
something however he never got there his
older brother got home later on and
thought it was strange that um his
brother was not there his brother wanted
to go home specifically cuz his little
brother was really into um war movies
and there was a movie coming on TV that
he really wanted to watch and so he was
leaving the American Legion Hall early
so he could go home and watch this movie
so his brother thought it was really
weird that he got home and you know Mark
was not there so he hadn't come home uh
by 11:00 p.m. so his mom obviously
panicked and uh called the police to
report him missing they gave him the
runaround at first like they did a lot
oh the kids just just to run away you
have to wait 24 hours blahy blah there
was that whole thing now they found him
um you know obviously they looked
everywhere for him and they didn't find
him they didn't find him until 4 days
later um February
19th there was a kind of a businessman
who was walking his dog um kind of
toward this drugstore like behind a
strip mall type situation the uh I think
it's called the New Orleans mall and he
saw what he thought was a man now if you
know anything about True Crime you know
that it's never a [__] mannequin
sadly it's always like a dead body I
mean I guess every now and then it might
be a man might be in rig mortis you know
what I mean so the arms are up and it's
like something came out of a store
window it's probably what they're
talking about but it's just it kills me
that every that every time somebody
finds a body and it's like they find a
body just laying on the side of the road
there I was like well I thought it was a
mannequin at first it's like it's never
a mannequin and it was not in this case
either um now so the the body was
dressed he had all his cloes clothes on
um you know so the guy is just kind of
like holy [__] that's a kid's body this
was about 11: like about4 to 12 in the
morning
11:45 now when they kind of um asked
around there was another person that had
been walking their dog in the same area
early like about 2 hours earlier to
about 9:30 in the morning and they had
not seen the body and they were like now
if that body had been there at 9:30 the
dog would have smelled it would have
found it you know what I mean cuz it
wasn't hidden I saw the crime scene
photos it was right there so between 9
and 11 it was Dum so at some point
between 9:30 and 1145 the body was was
dumped they they
thought um so Mark uh you know the
victim he was in seventh grade at
Lincoln Junior High School he was kind
of um a quiet kid um just only about 100
PBS 4' 8 now they said that his cause of
death was um as IIA he'd been smothered
um there were also rope burns on his
neck his wrists and his ankles like cons
he'd obviously been tied up bondage and
he had also been sexually assaulted yeah
um as I said he had been uh bathed and
his clothes had been washed and put back
on him before he was dumped now there
was kind of a [__] up with the um I
guess the autopsy team like washed the
body which I guess they're not really
supposed to do but they watched it like
earlier than they should have which you
know that gets rid of evidence so they
couldn't get any fingerprints off the
body or anything like
that so that was the first
victim the second victim was also 12
years old but this time it was a girl
her name was Jill
Robinson now this was December 22nd
1976 now her and her mom had had an
argument uh from what they said she was
kind of going through that teenage or
pre-teen phase where you know you like
you can't you're not the boss of me and
you can't tell me which you know a lot
of teenagers go through that so she had
an argument with her mom her mom wanted
her to stay home and make biscuits for
dinner and Jill said no and her mom
whose name was Carol got really mad at
her and said well why don't you just get
out of here and come back when you can
be part of this family which I'm sure
she probably regrets like saying that
now because
this was the last time that she saw her
daughter which is [__] up so Jill
actually goes into her room she packs a
little backpack and she leaves the house
now she went off on her bike now her mom
was not alarmed because one it's the 70s
and two um her daughter had done it
before and she just said oh you know
she's just mad she'll just ride her bike
to her friend's house or the neighbor's
house or she'll go to her dad's house
which wasn't that far away cuz the
parents were divorced um you know and
then when she's when she's over it
she'll come back cuz she had done it
before and it was only like you know it
was only a few days before Christmas she
was really looking forward to Christmas
and she said well she's not going to
stay away for that she'll be back like
soon so that's why she wasn't super
worried about it now apparently the girl
was seen by uh a friend at like a hobby
shop on Woodward Avenue and um that was
only a few blocks away from her
house now
the girl was gone pretty much all day
and
night um now her dad was the one that
reported her missing like the following
morning I believe it was now some people
did say that they had seen her like a at
a donut shop like around 6:30 in the
morning like on the day that her dad
reported her missing I don't know if
that's true or not but some people did
say they saw her
there now her body was not found for
several days again four days um they
found her the day after Christmas and
she was found on the side of
I75 now
interestingly what happened in this she
was not sexually assaulted she was she
had also been bathed she had been
redressed she had all her clothes on the
killer brought her to this area and shot
her with a shotgun in the head or some
sources say the face just right where
she stood like an execution and then
just left her
there um but she had also been kept in
captivity for several days but then for
whatever reason the killer just took her
out to the side of the road and shot her
and then just left her there but did not
sexually assault her did they find the
body like four days later yeah what time
um I don't know what he did that in the
middle of the night or he did that in
the daytime I have no idea he must have
done that in the middle of the night
when there wasn't any there wasn't much
traffic yeah because from my
understanding the place where they found
the body was um a fairly high traffic
area yeah took her out and blasted her
he wasn't happy with
her yeah that's what I'm saying he
wasn't happy with her she wasn't
sexually assulted maybe she struggled
too much yeah not sure and said
something to him pissed him off he kept
her for a few days he tried to break her
or something didn't work he didn't get
what he watered out of her he went and
[__] blew her head off
which is off yeah it's a 12 that's a
12-year-old [__] girl he just did
this dude doesn't care well yeah
obviously yeah obviously he's mentally
mentally [__] not
there yeah this is [__] up this is
[__] up he imagined it going down a
certain way didn't go that way he was
frustrated maybe so couldn't get her to
cooperate he killed her the boy
cooperated in some way yeah so I believe
I believe that Jill Robinson was the
only one that was shot yeah um um the
other ones were like I said strangled or
suffocated but she was shot and he just
took her because they said she that she
died where her body was found uh not
that I know of I don't think she'd been
tied up I'm not really
sure so when they found her on the
ground she wasn't tied up though no she
wasn't restrained
M well the first one the first kid
wasn't either but they but he had like
burn marks he was dead when he was
delivered yeah all right she was killed
on the spot which means he drove her
there she was alive yeah so I have a
feeling he lied to her about maybe he
told her he was going to let her go
going to let her go and uh she got out
of the car and he shot her shot her with
a shotgun he must [__] horrible which
tells me it's probably a sought off
shotgun something more portable than the
long gun yeah he had a shotgun and
probably saw it off something short
about a foot
long double barrel probably it's [__]
horrible I mean can you [__] imagine
I can't
imagine we didn't have a pistol probably
uh he would have used a pistol if he had
it but he had a sought off shotgun he
had a shotgun he turned into a pistol
that's that's what I'm seeing yeah so
the shotgun itself was just that's just
because that's what he had
yeah and
um he didn't want to make a mess in his
own
house so he took her to a place where he
was going to dump her and shot her there
but she was underf she thought he was
letting her she thought that he thought
that he was going to let her go probably
in the final minutes he says you didn't
you basically cussed her and [__]
shot
her
yep yeah again folks this is a grown man
and a 12-year-old girl mentally he's
about like that level probably anyway
yeah no he's definitely a
pedophile yeah a PDF file well yeah they
know that like I said we'll get into
definitely we'll get into all that kind
of [__] later on because yeah man this
area it at this time I don't know about
nowadays but man there were just PDF
files all over the [__] place place
place was lousy with PDF files you know
just they kept uncovering more like
during the investigation they're just
kind of like well this guy isn't the
killer but oh look we found this nest of
other PDF files look at that it was just
in this one area you know they're
[__] everywhere so the third victim
is named uh Christine melich I think is
how melich or mik I'm not really sure
how you pronounce her last name now this
girl was 10 uh again the first three
victims I think their parents were
divorced the weird thing about it is
they seem to be targeting specific kind
of kids they were usually like CH
Children of Divorce which you know is
common nowadays but in the 70s wasn't
quite as common um also the first three
kids were sort of said to be kind of um
introverted or quote unquote loners uh
the fourth one which we'll get into not
so much but these first three were like
likely to be walking around by
themselves yeah that's probably that's
all it is probably um but yeah so this
girl was 10 like I said she was in the
fifth grade uh she was in elementary
school now she was last seen alive
January 2nd
1977 so day after New Year's um she'
been at the bowling alley where her mom
worked and she walked she was just
walking over to 7-Eleven like to get
some get a magazine or
something um now her body was found uh
by a a mailman lying in a
snowbank um at the end of a dead end
Street um and Frankl in Franklin Village
I think is the name of the place now
this was on January 21st so she was gone
the longest uh they didn't find her for
19 days he keeps them for a long time
that's yeah I mean the the previous two
had been kept for 4 days uh this girl
was kept the longest 19 days because
when they found her body um she hadn't
been dead that long yeah he so he'd been
keeping her somewhere he liked her he
that's why he kept her for so long so
she was giving him what he
wanted yeah she was going along with it
maybe so and then he got bored with her
yeah yeah that's or she just couldn't
take it anymore started talking [__] so
he would then he killed her in some way
but yeah so they um like I said all all
these uh happened like in the winter
time too so was like super snowy like
you said it's kind of like Siberia um
this is [__] up but when they found
her body it was so Frozen that they
couldn't even do an autopsy on it like
they had to wait for it to like thaw out
she was like like frozen solid well she
yeah and she hadn't been dead long okay
like I said this is January in Michigan
yeah so it's how what was what was the
death it's [__] cold caus a death
well I haven't got to that yet okay um
now they found no signs of violence on
the body she was not sexual assaulted
she was wearing the same clothes that
she had last been seen in uh which again
had been
washed um now her cause of death was
listed as
Suffocation yeah so this not sexually
assaulted that's that's [__] she was
sexually assaulted just not in a way
that showed up well like a yeah well
that yeah and some people have said that
too it's because a lot of people were
like oh well um you know the boys were
very clearly sexually assaulted the two
boys which you know we'll get into the
the fourth one which is also a boy a
minute and the two girls didn't look
like they were but like you said that
doesn't necessarily mean that there
weren't because there are other ways to
sexually assault somebody that doesn't
necessarily wouldn't necessarily show up
yeah I I what I'm assuming is is that
when they checked the highman were
intact so they were technically
virgins um but and he may may have been
oral or manual stuff happen that's what
I mean and that wouldn't show up
obviously like what if like what if not
to be gross but what if he had like put
forced his dick into her mouth or
something like that like obviously that
wouldn't show up on an autopsy talked
her into just blowing him well that's
what I said yeah yeah yeah so the thing
is is you and that's still absolutely
sexual assault but that doesn't show up
on well he kept that one for a long time
so she was probably going along with
it scared well yeah you're going to do
this yeah this is what you're going to
do and probably you know telling her you
know teaching her what to do and she did
it until got sick of her or she got sick
of sick of doing this and she started
rebelling and then okay time for you to
go yeah the other one he probably tried
to get what he wanted out of her for
days something happened he he took it
personally and he shot her in the face
yeah or in the back of the head like I
said I've seen I've seen sources that
close and that close range and probably
something like a 20 gauge or a 12 gauge
if you can't tell the [__] front for
the back I've seen head shots from
[__] 12 gauge up close suicides fol
photographs of it it's mess but he would
probably right up on her it blows right
through it especially if it's something
like Buckshot which is a heavier
pellet and the same thing with with a
slug it' probably be well you'd probably
see powder Burns if it was at contact
distance you'd know what was front and
back just the the forensics of the time
and who's doing the the test may not
have known in those
days ballistic science was was n as
[__] easily easily researched as it
is today I mean today you can go on
YouTube and see guys shooting ballistic
gelatin torsos that have fake skeletons
in it to show you exactly what these
things do at different
ranges different calibers and stuff so
back in those days some of the [__] that
[__] these uh guys on YouTube are
testing and doing and evaluating when I
was a kid in the 80s reading guns and
ammo what they were doing was [__]
light what they're doing today is light
years ahead of what we knew back
then well that's kind of true of pretty
much everything that's going on nowadays
we're like way ahead of get a little
[__] camera for a couple hundred
dollars that has such good high-speed
photographic capabilities that can
capture a bullet in Flight slow motion
now and in the 80s man that was a
million dooll camera that would did that
so you know almost nobody had that we
kind of take it for granted how like
easy everything is nowadays you know
what I mean right which I try not to
take it for granted because I remember
when [__] wasn't like that right but now
it's just like getting any any
information getting [__] is so easy and
like a lot of stuff that'll do like
amazing [__] is like super cheap yeah
but just telling you that he he shot her
in the head with a shotgun instead of
just smothering her or strangling her
cuz that's an easier way to go that was
malice he was mad at that one that one
didn't go well for him and he only kept
her four
days so although the first one the their
first boy was only CT for 4 days I'll
say they found probably got sick of that
[__] too and he definitely was raped
yeah and he was also tied up which means
he was struggling yeah
so I got a feeling that's not what he
wants he wants a a he wants a uh someone
who's submissive it'll do whatever
that'll do what ever said yeah he wants
somebody who's into it which uh yeah
good luck with that like just snatching
12-year-olds off the [__] Street yeah
yeah well he's trying to fulfill a
fantasy yeah how about uh don't do that
you know he's [__] nuts yeah no [__]
and like I said we still don't know who
this [__] is yeah I mean he
might be dead he might be in prison for
something else I don't really know but
nobody really knows exactly who he is so
the for he's trying to abduct a little
underage porn star yeah but that's not
what's happening yeah he's getting
mad which is so stupid it's like what
the [__] what the [__] do you expect you
just like snatch random ass Street he's
a lunatic and and then you're like
shocked when it doesn't go the way you
think it's going to go it's like yeah
what did you think was going to happen
ID he's also trying to adapt to this to
see if he can train
one you
know he's trying to trying to figure out
you know should he use the stick or the
carrot you know he's trying to figure
out psychology how to get him to do
this for the thing with the girls is
that sounds like he was into
virgins some guys will just [__] rape
you know yeah do it maybe so but for
some reason there was something about
their virginity was attractive to
them yeah that's kind of messed up I
always wondered why some dudes had like
an obsession with that CU they're
untouched and innocent so you're getting
an innocent girl to do this and if
you pop a seal on it in your mind in his
fantasy she's no longer totally innocent
she's not brand
new yeah yeah it's just a weird it's a
weird you got to put yourself in the
shoes of these [__] c yeah I know I
know I can do it just by just going
straight Primal to the [__] gutter
you know of
how [__] immature [__] would
see it well like I said intellectually I
understand that um but I don't you know
obviously I can't relate to that and
it's just seems really alien to me
because that's not the way I think about
stuff but like I said it's you know
intellectually I get it like it makes
sense when when it's explained like why
they would think that I understand all
kinds of that makes sense but I
understand all kinds of kick there's a
lot of [__] dark side kick I'm not
into but I can understand why someone
would the motive I can see the motive
you know which like I said and I've said
this many times before I don't have a
problem with it as long as everyone is
over the correct age and everyone is
consenting do what you want
but the minute you start involving
people that aren't consenting or people
that are underage then we've got a big
problem what he's going for here is
virgins of both
sexes that's that's that's the thing
he's into this innocence
thing and uh he's trying to get an
innocent little porn star of both sexes
that's basically he's somebody who's
going to [__] deliver that's what
that's what it feels like maybe he's
trying out both things to see what he
likes better I think he knows what he
likes he's bisexual but he's he's trying
to figure out how to get it from out of
him yeah because evidently there's a
right way and a wrong way because you
can tell by how long that they're living
and what how he kills them what happens
to him in the end they're all going to
die but some of them are going to die
worse than the others
yeah and long and and later than the
others right so that girl lasted 14 days
19 days or 19 days and then he just
strangled that one which that or
smothered her smothered her to him
that's like a peaceful way to go that's
the way he sees it like a youth in Asia
that's how he sees it so she did pretty
well in his mind for a little while I
think he wants to keep them yeah he
wants to keep them I think for
years yeah because there are some of
these [__] that'll do that
yeah they'll just like remember did we
do a did we do a show about remember
those people that had that girl and they
kept her in that box under the bed
yeah I kept her there for what 9 years
it was a long time and she survived that
weird and he was doing good [__] to her
he put her head in a box too leave her
head in a box for days she could I don't
remember if we did a show about that or
not but that is I think we did that show
that is a messed up it's called the girl
in a box yeah that's a mess up case yeah
they kept her in a box under the bed and
it was a couple that was doing it yeah
which yeah that always like blows my
mind I you know it's no offense to dudes
but it's just like it doesn't shock me
like when dudes do [__] like this but
when it's a couple cuz we've done some
shows about killer couples we used to do
on every Valentine's Day which I know is
messed up but the dynamic of that is
just so fascinating to
me yeah what's weird in that particular
case you just talked about that his wife
is terrified of it yeah see that's
another thing too it's like it's not
always like sometimes you get a case
where the woman is just as messed up or
more messed up than he is but a lot of
times too I think it's a kind of case of
him either threatening her into it or
talking her into it like a frog in
boiling water situation yeah or she's
trying to impress him by doing worse
[__] than he's doing well that British
couple uh the the girls that survived
that British couple said that the woman
was worse who Fred and rosemary West
yeah Rosemary West they said that she
was that they were much more afraid of
her and she was weird she was doing
weird [__] to her own sons and
stuff so you know she was she was weird
too yeah I mean there's weirdos of both
sexes that's for sure she'd leave porn
out for the son little boy Sons to find
it then she' go in there and spank him
for long periods of time for watching
porn and doing kind of sexual [__] for
with with weird it's a weird situation
and we haven't done a show about it but
um the uh if you guys have read the Jack
catch them novel The Girl Next Door
which is based on um the Sylvia lyans I
don't think we've done a show a show
about her I have been wanting to for a
while even though that's a [__]
messed up case too but that was actually
not a couple that was just a woman and
she did some messed up [__] and that was
like back in the 50s or 60s or something
like that that woman was a
lunatic but yeah yeah mango said the
wests were seriously [__] up oh yeah
big time Big Time there's some uh you
know and that's the thing like I write
about about True Crime a lot and I read
about True Crime a lot so it's just kind
of like some always kind of like trust
no one you know what I mean but you know
most people are relatively normal
but you know you got to you got to watch
your ass because there are some real
real [__] up people out there really
[__] up including this [__] or
[__] this could be more than
one person I'm kind of I think it's well
I don't know we'll see like I said you
haven't you haven't heard all the
information yet he might had a sidekick
there's no way of know him so the fourth
canonical victim was named Timothy King
and he was
11 and he was last seen on March 16th
1977 now he had actually he borrowed 30
cents from his older sister so he could
go down to the pharmacy and buy some
candy uh which was it was only three
blocks he had done it many many times
before um it was evening I
believe now he actually went to the
store and the lady that worked at the
store said yeah he came in and bought
candy it was about 8:30 at night and he
left the store through the back door
like there was a parking lot back there
and there wasn't really a lot of light
so it was kind of like dark back there
because it's winter time you know what I
mean now he had been planning to come
back home like come right back home
because his older sister was going out
but he said to his older sister hey can
you leave the door to the house a jar
cuz I don't have my key you know what I
mean so I can get back in the house so
she did that and then she went out but
um Timothy never came home his parents
came home at 9:00 and did not find him
there and were alarmed so they started
looking everywhere for him and then the
next morning they called the cops uh to
look for him now there had actually
aside from you know him being the fourth
one that had been missing and like been
murdered there had also been a couple of
other missing persons cases that weren't
related to this one so Timothy was
actually the seventh like child that had
gone missing in this area in this time
period so everyone was a little on edge
as you might
imagine so um they actually set up the
cop set up kind of like a headquarters
type of thing like only a few blocks
from from his house and started
canvasing the neighborhood looking for
him however they did not find him until
March 23rd I think it's 23rd I can't
really see yeah 23rd
1977 uh they found him in a ditch
alongside of a road um in uh
Leonia now he was actually found by a
passing motorist um and again he was
just right it was like a real busy
intersection and he was just found in a
ditch like right there like off the side
of the road
again he had the same clothes on that he
had been wearing when he disappeared um
and his skateboard which he had actually
ridden to the pharmacy was found about
15 ft away so he must have been in the
back seat he stops dude stops at a light
or just stops when no cars are around
him jumps out opens opens the rear
passenger seat throws the boy out he's
big he's strong enough to just grab him
by an arm throw his ass out then throw
the skateboard out and drive off before
the other cars catch up with him yeah
that's what he's
doing so he's probably driving around
until there's a break in traffic it's
probably not a pre-planned area where
just general area where he's going to
dump yeah dump the body like I said he
seemed to want the bodies to be found
because he was dumping them in really
high traffic
areas yeah he might be reading into it
too much it might just be that he wasn't
all that careful he just was like well
long as no one sees me do it there's no
reason why I should go out of my way D
with his body you know just on off of a
road road from away away from where he
lived yeah wasn't the kind of guy to
just go out [__] in the wilderness or
you know bury the kid you know he wasn't
that kind of guy that's what I'm
thinking it is he's just trying to it's
minimal effort I think
yeah so they did an autopsy um just like
the other victims uh he had been bathed
and you know his clothes had been washed
and he'd been redressed before he was uh
he was killed by being uh suffocated
uh there was also uh evidence that he
had been uh again sexually assaulted
just like the other boy and he had been
fed KFC which was his favorite thing to
eat before he was killed so he's trying
to befriend him yeah he's not telling
him what that that's the last meal he's
just what what what's your favorite
place you get and then he ate it and
then he he killed which like I said is
[__] heartbreaking when you think
about that this is an 11year old kid
yeah you know what I mean how long did
he have him um he disappeared let me see
he disappeared on March 16th right March
16th and then they found him on the 23rd
you had him for a few days five days
five or six days yeah
yeah so so he didn't have anything for
seven days strange seven yeah so
strangely in this dude's mind that kid
did well he didn't have anything against
him but he's got to kill them all that's
part of his day fed him his last meal
and killed him
cold blooded it yeah very cold blooded
yeah so it was think he's doing him a
favor though uh yeah I guess so yeah so
it was at this stage that the cops
finally kind of clued into the fact that
this was a serial killer uh so at this
point they did a task force and like I
said they started like the largest
Manhunt in US history at the time like
obviously it's been superseded since
that time but at the time it was back in
the 70s uh meanwhile Timothy King's dad
Barry king um established a fund in his
son's honor they're trying to kind of
give financial assistance to abuse
children and things of that nature
although sadly Barry King died in 2020
without ever finding out what happened
to his son I believe he was in his 80s
which is pretty shitty but he ran that
fund like that whole 40s something years
like up until he so this kid was 10 11
11 girl that got shot in the face was 12
mhm the other the other boy was what was
also 12 and then the other girl was 10
10 got the feeling that he got better at
doing what he was doing as he went
along yeah maybe that's yeah he got he
thinks he got better at it he got I
think he I think he basically kind of
got what he wanted out of that last
one kept him for 10 days seven days it
seven days played around with him and
then got bored with him
but gave him an easy death and a reward
and an easy death in in in his mind so
he was just trying to erase the kid that
like that the kid had happened you know
what I mean like like it never happened
type of deal the girl shooting the girl
in the face man there was some bad blood
there but she was fighting with her mom
so she was probably pretty
defiant yeah she says something to him
that assaulted him and he's like that's
I'm going take this check out kill her
you know do something bad to her he
probably didn't tell her she was going
to kill her he probably told her he was
going to let her
go or she why would she you know she
would have jumped out of the car right
yeah cuz I'm like yeah [__]
you're not taking me anywhere I'd rather
jump out and get some [__] road rash
yeah then be taken to another location I
don't think she was tied up I mean she
didn't appear that she'd been tied up
when they found
her so not long after uh Timothy King
had vanished um there was a witness a
woman and she told the police that she
had seen allegedly uh a boy carrying a
skateboard because like I said Timothy
King had had had ridden a skateboard to
the to get candy and she said that she'd
seen this kid talking to somebody in the
parking lot of the pharmacy like on
March 16th the day he disappeared so she
was able to give them a good enough
description for them to do like a
composite drawing and she also said that
he was driving a blue AMC
Gremlin so at this stage in this area
they actually um suspended the Fourth
Amendment they pulled over and searched
every single Gremlin that was on the
road that they spotted uh and as another
documentary I was watching said it's
like probably some people that drove
Gremlins got pulled over and searched
like multiple times cuz how many of them
could there possibly be in that area I
don't know how common was the gremlin
back then uh I feel like it wasn't that
common well they had Pacers and Gremlins
and yeah well there was a lot of cars
that kind of looked the same you know
which we'll yeah now why did they why
did they think he had a gremlin because
this woman said that she'd seen a boy
with a skateboard talking to somebody
that was standing next door a gremlin in
the parking lot of the pharmacy where
the kid had gone to buy candy okay she
said all right like on the day that he
disappeared yeah all right so they got
all up yeah they got all up in this AMC
Gremlin thing um they kind of found out
later that either the gremlin thing was
either like maybe just a red herring
like maybe that wasn't even the guy or
the car was maybe disposed of like
shortly after that lead came to light
like the killer was like oh [__] now
they're going to be looking for that so
like maybe dumped it in a ravine or or
like a [__] quy or something um or
she might have been mistaken about what
kind of car it was you know what I mean
so I I don't know we'll get into that
like a little bit
too so at this point they established a
profile like I said they were able to do
um like a composite drawing of what they
thought that he looked like now this was
the guy that she said that she had seen
talking to the kid with a skateboard she
said the guy looked between 25 and 35
years old um had kind of a dark he was a
white guy but he had kind of a dark
complexion had roll shaggy hair and
sideburns which it's the 70s a lot of
people had that um and they also
surmised just from the kind of the way
that the crimes were committed they said
it could be that this
dude would maybe had a kind of
profession or a kind of demeanor that
made him seem not threatening uh at some
stages they even thought maybe he
dressed as a cop or a priest or maybe he
was a teacher or something like that
like something that the kids would not
immediately distrust him you know what I
mean so they were kind of operating on
that assumption too they also thought
this was a person that's very familiar
with the area um and you know had some
kind of house where they either lived
alone or where they could keep these
kids for a long time without anyone
being suspicious about it so there's
that um the profiler they did kind of do
like a psychological profile on the guy
um and they thought that the killer was
probably uh maybe more intelligent and
educated than
average um was probably gay they thought
that he had a regular 9 to-5 job that
gave him a lot of vacation time in the
winter months cuz that's when most of
the [__] happened and and I'm not really
sure how they figured this out but they
said they thought the dude was probably
seeing a therapist like a psychiatrist
not really sure how they got that out of
all of stuff how do they get gay out of
that if he was gay he wouldn't have
abducted girls well yeah well I think
they were operating on the assumption
that because the the boys were obviously
raped and the girls were not I think
that was maybe and maybe they had some
other information that I'm privy to um
that made them think that but but like
you said yeah it doesn't just because
the girls weren't obviously like weren't
obviously like vaginally or anally raped
that doesn't mean they weren't sexually
assaulted in other ways yeah you know
what I mean well look at somebody like
you know I know we bring up BTK a lot
but look at somebody like BTK he never
like raped anybody yeah but the crimes
were still sexual and he did like jerk
off
on that little dead girl yeah didn't
have sex with her but he jerked off on
her like after she was dead yeah which
like I said that's still I don't you
know that's he's weird yeah so I'm
saying there's lots of other ways to
yeah look at that I think he was just I
think he was by seexual he just wanted
different things had different standards
for different Sexes different genders of
person things he wanted to do with boys
and things he wanted to do with girls
that's that's they're just being
narrow-minded yeah but like I said that
might have been like what they would
have thought back then back then right
like I think nowadays they'd maybe have
like a broader right look at it but I
think like I said they I'm they might
have they might be using other
information that I don't know have but
I'm assuming that because the boys were
obviously raped and the girls were not
obviously raped why would you go through
all the hassle and the risk of of of
abducting a female if you weren't going
to get any gratification out of it yeah
cuz that's what you're you're generally
your your PDF file serial killers yeah
will generally kidnap whatever gender
they're into yeah uh so you're going to
have one that just kidnaps little boys
or one that just kidnaps little girls
it's very unusual to find one that'll
kidnap either one yeah but I think this
is one of them well yeah yeah and he
just has a different fantasy for each
one yeah for for each sex each
gender yeah and like you said and and it
might have just been a failure of the
imagination of the investig I got a
feeling that when it comes came to girls
he liked virgins yeah that was his thing
he didn't want to take their
virginity which is yeah that's weird but
I but I see where you're yeah yeah I
mean that does sound kind of plausible
to me yeah he had different standards
for him yeah bad dwell says they're back
the coolest people you'd ever meet at a
bar we are actually and you will meet us
at at many different bars cuz we go to
bars all the time uh he says they got
their tasty drinks I join you but I just
woke up and I don't like to drink within
the first hour the first 3 hours of
waking yeah I'm just I got vodka and um
it's CR it's cran pineapple actually but
yeah see here it's like 8:30 at night so
it's fine it's fine that we
drink so I actually well I was going to
say I need a refill but I guess I don't
finish that first yeah okay we don't
have any um any more of that cray yeah I
was use I was using it up yeah so before
we get on to the crack and open the new
orange
juice so here's something weird and I
don't
know um if this has anything to do with
anything but a few weeks after Timothy
King was
murdered there was um as I mentioned
they had set up a task force at this
point because they're you know obviously
it's a serial killer now they had a
psychiatrist on the task force and he
received a letter presumably addressed
to him
and this letter which was written very
badly um you know was misspellings
everywhere this was written by somebody
who called themselves
Allen this person claimed that they were
the satom masochistic slave of the
killer who they called
Frank and we'll get into later like why
the Frank thing might be
significant now Allan explained that him
and Frank had served together in
Vietnam and that Frank had been horribly
traumatized by having to kill children
while he was in
Vietnam and that he decided that he was
going to take revenge on richer people
for sending them to Vietnam in the first
place which again sounds like a reach
but okay sounds fishy as [__] it does
but this person that wrote this letter
Allan who said he was his slave he said
you know I'm going crazy over here i'
I'm in danger I'm terrified of him and
he said that he was
suicidal and he said that he had
actually gone with Frank when the um
when Frank was going looking for victims
right now he told the psychiatrist it's
like look if you got this letter and you
know you want to respond to me then um
take out an ad like in the Detroit Free
Press on Sunday that says weather Bureau
says trees to bloom in 3 weeks like so
he'd know that he got it or
whatever now he also said in this letter
that he's like I'll send you
photos um of what I'm talking about if
you can guarantee that I will not be
prosecuted now the psychiatrist did what
he asked like he ran the ad and he like
was going to meet up with with him and
everything like that but probably not
surprisingly this Allen person did not
show up and they never got another
letter from him again so was this just a
crank probably crank um but yeah well
like I said there there was something to
do with the name Frank that was kind of
like significant later on but I don't
know that it sounds a little out there
to me but weirder things have happened
you know what I mean I just thought I
would mention it CU that's some like
kind of a weird detail in the case
so while the task force was
going um they got almost 20,000 tips uh
all of which they had to investigate now
they actually arrested about two dozen
people but it was on unrelated
charges now while they were doing this
investigation they came across a
Multistate uh Kitty prawns ring which
was operating on North Fox Island in
Lake Michigan so this is kind of like
the Epstein's Island before Epstein's
Island let's put it that way because
what was going on here that they
discovered and like I said this might or
might not be related to the Oakland
County child killer case um there's
arguments either way so they're doing
the investigation and they come across
this whole thing this whole PDF file
ring they arrest two dudes one of them
is named Frank Sheldon like I said
there's Frank he's a millionaire he was
from gr Point Michigan uh he was a
geologist I believe and he was also like
heir to this big Lumber Company fortune
or whatever and then there was also
Jerry Richards his associate who was a
gym teacher yeah that almost seems like
too perfect you know what I mean he's
one of those weird gym teachers that
stands in the shower and like watches
all the boys naked and Pats them on the
ass and all that kind stff achieve
better posture right that kind offf
yeah he was like that he was he was like
that like every that you think about
like the weirdo gym teacher that all of
us had in school like this guy was like
the the platonic ideal of that so so
yeah so these two [__]
faces um so Sheldon who like I said was
a millionaire
multi-millionaire he actually owned um
not the entire Island I don't think
North Rock Island but a large chunk of
it and what they would do because they
were both PDF files is that Jerry the
teacher would evidently allegedly um
kind of recruit boys and then fly them
to the
island now under what offices who knows
okay um I don't really
know so Sheldon he has the whole [__]
Island kitted out man he's got like a
landing strip he's got like um you know
a boat dock thing uh he's got like all
these cabins that built on there and uh
you know he had like the private jet
that he flew kids back and forth on
there and he had cameras all over the
island and it was kind of one of those
things where like as soon as you got to
the island cuz I saw some interviews
with some well they're not kids now
obviously they're adults but when they
were kids they had you know allegedly
been taken to this place and um they
said yeah like when you got there like
and usually through the gym teacher cuz
he's like hey we're going to this cool
like camp or whatever like this cool
vacation yeah and so I I guess that's
how they talked him into it they started
was like a Boy Scout camp or something
yeah you know those cabins and we're
going camping and [__] yeah so they
would to take him out there and then
basically as soon as they got there the
boys said it's like you like oh everyone
has to take their clothes off now like
the boys and the adults yeah so
everybody just has to walk around naked
at all times and there were cameras
apparently all over the island so they
would film Kitty prawn and then trade it
and sell it it would immediately become
a nudest colony soon as you showed up
essentially that's what they that's what
they said like that's what cuz like I
said I saw some interviews with like
some some guys that yeah yeah yeah now
they would actually uh how I'm going to
say without getting in trouble well
probably too late now they would
actually transact with these boys so
they just made the boys walk around I'm
assuming that they did transact with
them because one of the guys that was
interviewed that said he had been taken
there as a child yeah um was that yeah
every now and then like one of the boys
would get taken to one of the cabins or
something like that and like you hear
screaming and [__] oh damn so hear him
screaming how old were these boys these
teenagers or no like um like pre-teen oh
[__] okay yeah yeah 10 11 yeah not old
enough to defend themselves right around
that age the parents would have to let
them go that's what I mean and well and
they said weren't scared they'd go back
to the parents that was well that was
the shitty thing was that like I said
this was a teacher like in a lot of
their schools so that's kind of how he
he apparently used his position to
recruit a lot of these kids hey we're
going on this fun like I said like
summer camp type type [__] yeah
billionaires and then yeah and it's like
oh I've got a friend that's got this big
island he's got all these cabins it's
really neat you know what I mean and
like back then like little kids be like
they tell these kids they say look
you're going to get in trouble if they
find out that this [__] happened because
[__] I'm rich and Powerful we'll flip
all this [__] around your your parents
don't make they probably do yeah your
parents don't make anywhere near enough
money okay to fight us well look at what
look at what when we did the show about
Michael Jackson now I feel like Michael
Jackson wasn't quite as blatant as that
yeah but dudes that are like PDF files
like that I mean they're good at like
manipulating kids and a lot of time this
is a kid you know what I mean they don't
know and this isn't an adult the thing
is who has a lot of power over them
who's telling them I'm coming to
Jackson's [__] defense Michael
Jackson was smooth he was he was a
smooth criminal you're just ignorant you
know what I'm saying just ignorant well
that's he went about it slightly he took
time right you know what I mean they
call that grooming is what they call
that all right he made sure that the
kids loved him they they did they they
loved it they said he did but then when
they got older they realized man that
[__] Bamboozled me yeah yeah
yeah well that's what so [__] up about
it is that like sometimes the kid
doesn't really know they're too young to
right it depend I mean it depends on the
kid yeah but I mean some kids were you
know just kind of like oh well I guess
this is okay this is an adult and
well he only had basically adoring fans
right come we're talking about you know
uh MJ MJ only like super fans yeah so
they he already had them in his pocket
they and you don't really want to think
that like this person that is your idol
is a bad person you know so I get it but
I think he was using that to his
Advantage yeah go back and see our
Michael Jackson show you you you had
seen it you'll like but it's but what he
was doing that's kind of the point that
I was getting at was like what he was
doing is like just on the same Spectrum
as what the as what all PDF files do
yeah right especially ones that like to
groom is you know what I mean CU
sometimes people are like oh my God like
why would a kid go along or anything
like that one they're a kid two
especially ones that are kind of more
trusting of adults or or they're scared
of adults and if the adult like knows
how to like talk to them and it's just
kind of like able to talk them into
doing this [__] right you know and if
that doesn't work a lot of times they'll
threaten them and know the kid is
scared used to be I thought that Jackson
was getting framed all right because the
people that were some of the people that
were accusing him had history of
accusing other people the thing is is
that he could be a PDF file and be
framed at the same time that was
happening yeah that's not mutually
exclusive both was happening he was
doing that and he was also being franked
by other people that were also made
money that way just that Jackson to go
back and listen to our show he he had an
entire stable he he had lots of them I I
was like that couldn't be no but then
looking back on it and then hearing the
the stories from the boys that were
involved now that they're adults it was
actually typical male rockar typical
male rock star Behavior he just happens
to be a PDF file he had a whole herum of
adoring fans that he slept with well it
was classic it was classic grooming and
it was probably easier for him because
like I said he was super famous and
nobody wants to believe yeah that
anybody that they idolize like that that
everybody loves is a terrible person and
Jackson thought there was nothing wrong
with it he thought he cared about these
kids yeah I I do genuinely believe he
wasn't a mean guy he was just sick yeah
you I do genuinely believe he did not
think that anything was wrong with it
yeah he he he loved Bo which just shows
how messed up he loved the boys but he
was also a player he'd make him jealous
he'd go out and sleep with one of them
take him upstairs and the other one's
like oh we know what they're doing up
there that [__] you know yeah
yeah yeah he's like that murder hor said
love the wig Jen thank you I really like
this one too actually I just got this
one on Sheen I think it was like four
bucks or something I need to get some
more cuz my other ones are getting kind
of full of knots and like all janky and
you get wig they they don't last that
long you know what I mean they get kind
of they're disposable yeah well it's
they're not real hair hey hey where you
going with it you still you still have
stuff to drink there yeah but I mean you
could kind of refill ice in it yeah okay
just I'm running out of ice I thought
you could just belt it down no I'm not
going to Belt It Down heaven sakes well
what kind of girl do you think I am but
yeah so so they're taking kids out to
this island and filming Kitty
prawns so these two [__] got either
arrested or indicted not sure Frank
Sheldon the millionaire because he has a
lot of money so obviously they get away
with pretty much everything as everyone
knows now he was able to actually flee
the country in 1976 uh so he was never
prosecuted I don't know where he went to
actually he might have gone to Holland
I'm not entirely sure
but yeah he [__] off and uh they they
never got him uh but he's dead now he
died in
1998 Now Jerry the gym teacher he did
get prosecuted um for Kitty prawns um he
is also dead though but he did go to
prison for it
thankfully now interestingly as I said
this whole North Fox Island situation
only came to light because they were
investigating the County Child Murders
but they don't think that either of
these two [__] are the killer but
what they do think there well what they
theorize is that because this island was
going for like 10 years right so they
think what might have happened is that
either someone who was victimized on the
island grew up and became a victimizer
like that's one Theory or the other
theory was that someone who patronized
the island and was an associate of
theirs was the killer but they don't
think that either one of those two dudes
are the killer they're both dead now
like I said and only one of them got
punished for the [__] CU Sheldon like
[__] took off Zack went on Google
Earth to go look at the island he he can
see the landing strip yeah see not
[__] it's weird right it's weird
what's what's with these PDF files in
their [__] private islands man secet
society I
guess just stop it
they make [__] dolls for that [__]
now you know what I mean which don't
look that up because it's kind of
disturbing we kind of came across it and
I was just kind of
like cuz Tommy's like he's like I'm G to
show you this but he's like I don't know
how I feel about it and I'm like I don't
know how I feel about it either I'm like
in a way it's kind of good CU it's like
well it's better than victimizing a real
kid um but on the other it's still hella
creepy like they're still hella creepy
but I guess it's better that they have
them than than not I guess I don't know
it's just kind of one of those things
that I feel really gross about and I'm
not really sure how to feel about it I
don't like looking at them they weird me
out but yeah so um so yeah so the task
force was going for a while but despite
all the tips and everything that they
had they didn't really get anywhere with
the investigation sadly so the task
force um kind of you know collapsed they
disbanded in uh at the end of 1978 and
which point the case was handed over to
the Michigan State
Police now here are some of the other
suspects that they were thinking about
like in relation to this crime so here's
this [__] named archabald
Sloan now he was a convicted PDF file um
and actually uh attacked Boys in his own
neighborhood now interestingly they
found some hair samples in his car which
was a 1966 um Pontiac
bonnaville now the hair that they found
in his car matched hair that was found
on Timothy King's body and Mark Stein's
body but the hair wasn't his meaning
that either someone who had been in the
car with him or someone he had loaned
the car to was likely the killer you see
what I'm saying like it wasn't his hair
but it was his car and hair that was in
the car was found on two of the bodies
but it wasn't his so somebody that was
in that car somebody that he knew or
somebody that he loaned the car to was
likely the killer okay you got that all
right so um now some people some
witnesses did say that when they when
Timothy King was abducted and this like
I said the lady that said she saw him
you know she said she saw like the one
guy like by the AMC Gremlin or whatever
but apparently there were some other
witnesses that said that they saw two PE
two guys um with him and that one of
them looked like John Wayne
gasy um however uh John Wayne gasy was I
I believe in Michigan in the area at in
the area at this time however they did
do DNA tests later like the DNA that
they had from the bodies and stuff like
that and they do have they did have
gas's DNA and it didn't match um so so
they did look into John Wayne gasy
because was kind of his bag how would
they have known each other though but
yeah that's what I mean well like I said
the PDF file Community is maybe very
small I'm not meet up at the PDF Island
that's what I mean it's just kind where
do they hang out like they have meetups
and stuff like that oh let's all go meet
at the Starbucks or some [__] like that
is messed up but they got to be doing
that they got to be doing that well it's
like I said before in other shows
intelligence agencies and [__] pick
picked that up from Germany the Germans
knew all about it even in the pre-nazi
era their intelligence agencies new
because Germany went through a bunch of
sexual revolutions and during the vinar
Republic era man [__] prostitution
and weird [__] was off the
chain so the intelligence agencies there
realized that you couldn't use the old
tricks in Germany of like you fooled on
your wife or you're gay so we're going
to tell on you you better obey us or we
tell that didn't work in Germany had to
be something a lot more unacceptable
PDF file action so the that's pretty
much always unacceptable well not pretty
much that's always unacceptable so what
the German intelligence agencies would
do is they would recruit child sex
operatives to ENT trap a Target and then
get which is somehow even more messed up
oh yeah well would that's what I'm
saying intelligence agencies need to be
[__] banned for the [__] that they do
and it's been MK Ultra [__] came out and
[__] related to that that's the in the
US Us in the US we had a psychologist in
Canada that would erase innocent
people's minds by putting them in dark
rooms covering them up drugging them
with LSD and putting reoccurring just
brainwashing uh [__] recordings over
and over in their heads for like a year
person on bed like that when they came
out they weren't even the same person
they were doing that to Housewives as a
test in Canada there CIA doing that they
wanted to know if they could erase a
person's
mind and replace it with a new person
make a mansurian candidates we did a
show on that
yeah well during Operation Paperclip
after the fall of Nazi
Germany our intelligence agencies got
all the information and technology and
all the good operatives and all the good
spies from the Third Reich ended up
working for the CIA and taught them
everything everything they
know you have that secret society of PDF
files you can use underage sex
operatives and trap people and get them
into that damn ring you can then the CIA
can run them on remote control for the
rest of their lives and make a lot of
money on it see they don't have any
oversight so the people that are in the
CIA can make millions and millions of
dollars and get property for their own
personal use using that
technique they run the show
partially it's dangerous man and that
that entity was never CIA was never
supposed to be a a a Perpetual
organization it was supposed to be just
temporary and it's still there and the
older those organizations get the more
corrupt they get well that's the thing
if you're an intelligence agency and the
[__] that you're doing to catch
so-called bad people is worse than what
the actual bad people are doing yeah
maybe you need to like that's what they
do and then they turn it in on other
people to make
money Tammy says if I had enough money
for a private island the last thing I
would want is a bunch of kids running
around on it right that's what I'm
saying yeah that's what I'm saying well
that's what I was saying you know
Michael Jackson looked awful guilty his
big old house had Ferris wheels and
trains on it and little statues of
[__] little white Peter Pans
everywhere and he was a guy in his 30s a
rock star [__] man if I had a [__] my
own [__] pad like that yeah it might
have a [__] train on it like a Mont
rail [__] landing strip that would be
kind of rad yeah not i' have I'd want
some rides I want some roller coasters
I'd have big booty statues all over the
place of H and [__] [__] it would be
nothing but porn stars in there and
[__] a whole yeah it' be a party 24/7
like a that's the way a rock star
actually should be living the ideal rock
star little Peter Pans and little boys
over at your house no little girls just
little boys that's weird spending the
night and dozen of them spending a night
with you for like weeks on end they
didn't weren't there just for a night
people some of those dudes there would
Liv there for weeks well some of that
their whole Ames likees Liv on the
compound for for they living with him
for weeks in his in his room yeah
sleeping in the same bed together Y and
he didn't even think anything was weird
about it he have two or three of I said
said if that was anybody else people
have been like the red flag is so big
you can see from [__] space that red
flag was should have been seen from
space well should have been they all
knew yeah I know just he was worth a lot
of money the big a lot of Industry
behind him they
knew they just knew that he knew well
enough to keep it hidden or under
wraps and then the media was running
interference for him oh no he's such a
nice
guy yeah whatever it was a nice guy but
he was doing that yeah I mean like I
said those two things aren't mutually
exclusive yeah yeah he's a nice guy but
he was also doing that you can also be a
PDF file and be a nice guy that's kind
of [__] up to think about but it's
like you don't have to be like a raging
no he wasn't the thing is you know I'm
saying he's I'm not saying he's a great
guy he was a nice he was not dangerous
is what I mean he was not physically
dangerous he thought what he was doing
was good yeah he thought he was helping
these kids he thought he was just he
thought it he thought that's what love
was yeah yeah for real he was [__]
messed up that's why Zach says oh Jesus
there's street view photos on the island
and it looks like some couple was cing
comping on it recently do you think they
know what happened there I would think
if they're from the Michigan area
probably because this is a pretty famous
case there still like Ranter were saying
they still it's still in the news like
every now and then
murder Hornet said watch out Jen I sent
Tom three vials of Tren LOL yeah right
just kidding he ear earlier said I'm
getting too small I need to go back on
Tren I didn't get bigger on Trent I if
anything I got smaller what are you
trying to get me to leave is that what's
going on I turn into a goddamn werewolf
again no I had enough of that so it's
trying to break us up yeah do not do TR
it's not that effective either yeah it's
not it's not worth it it didn't yeah
it's not worth the side effects there's
other stuff this [__] better yeah
[__] I mean you like I said you might
even if you don't have a girlfriend or
wife that'll leave you um you might end
up in prison yeah so 19 Nor testosterone
like NPP and deca are better and they're
so much easier on you
yeah okay so uh where were we okay so
John wayy there we go okay so here's
this other dude now this guy a lot of
people think this might be kind of the
Prime Suspect here now this dude was
arrested actually in Ohio and his name
is Ted lambor kind of like Lamborghini
but not lamborgine uh he was an auto
worker but he was retired and he was
also involved in a different PDF file
ring in the
1970s um and they went after boys
primarily um in Cass Corridor in Detroit
yeah now there were five dudes in the
ring uh lamborgine was one of only two
that were still living like they were
actually prosecuted in 2006 thank you so
much Bryce we really appreciate it I've
never heard of this case before it
sounds morbid and interesting yeah this
is a pretty depressing I mean anything
having to do with like PDF files and
child murder is depressing obviously but
thank thank you for that Super Chat yeah
thank you very much you you've been a
major contributor lately yeah yeah I
mean seriously we really do appreciate
yeah you're paying bills on this
house
you're paying for for Tom's new pull-up
bar yeah yeah yeah that he just ordered
yeah I got a new pull-up bar when it
doesn't wreck the door frame cuz the
other one just [__] up the door frame
it just [__] up it's a good pullup bar
but it [__] Push the door frame apart
it does yeah um so yeah so so this ring
was actually kind of busted up in 2006
but uh lamborgine was only one of two
remaining members of it that were still
alive now he was actually up for 19
counts of sexual assault on
children uh his partner in the ring who
was the other guy that was still alive
was named Richard Lawson uh and he was
uh had 28 charges of sexual assault on
children now in
2007 um they pretty much said that
lamborgine was the top suspect for the
Oakland County child killer like I said
it might be more than one person but
they're not sure they don't know if this
gu is is him but he's kind of the
favorite suspect at the moment now
interesting
in this particular case which wasn't
related to the Oakland child child
killer this was his Kitty prawns case or
his sexual assault against children case
he actually pleaded guilty like
immediately to
15 uh
counts now they said they would give him
a plea bargain if he would take a
polygraph regarding the Oakland County
child killings and he said no absolutely
not I'm
guilty which again is that's that's kind
of suspicious that he wouldn't take a
polygraph about the killings so he
confessed to
15 SE like separate sexual assaults on
kids because he didn't want to take a
polygraph that's weird they also and
they also said that he if he' take a
polygraph they' give him a reduced
sentence like after he was um you know
convicted and he again said
no yeah he thought he'd come up guilty
thought he would come up high so that's
I think that's why a lot of people think
that this might I mean you know and
polygraph tests are not real reliable I
get that but the fact that he was afraid
to take one and was like immediately
yeah I'm just going to go to prison
guilty guilty you know what I mean that
seems a little fishy seems a little
fishy just because you come up come up
bad on that polygraph test that doesn't
mean that they can actually indict you
on anything right they just wanted to
know if it was him he didn't want to
come he didn't want to he didn't want to
go along with it even for even for
reduced sentence he would have got it
yeah even if he failed he would have got
it yeah because I'm pretty sure I don't
know like all of the conditions yeah of
it but they were just like well in
exchange for taking a polygraph test to
do with the Oakland County child killer
case you can get a reduced sentence I
don't know like I said I don't know what
all the stipulations were but he said no
he wouldn't even do it we also don't
know exactly what the what the makeup of
these charges are and what the penalty
would have been in the 1970s because
strangely enough
people penalties for this kind of [__]
was actually pretty light back then it
was yeah
sadly how many count 30 counts of this
and that he probably was only looking at
a couple years if they run him
concurrent instead of
consecutive he might get six months on
each one running them all cons all
concurrent he's out in six
months which is crazy because they were
a lot more lenient on on sexual stuff
yeah because I've read about I mean it's
not great nowadays either but I've read
about like rape cases that were like
open and shut and like the dude got like
two years yeah or something like maybe
not even for for like violent like
jumping out of the bushes kind of rape
not not not that other kind of rape
aren't bad too but I'm just saying the
classic stranger rape that everybody
thinks of some dude did that and he just
got 24 months that's nothing yeah and he
just gets like two years or something
some dud think that oh that's worth it
it's worth it that's what I mean I'll do
six or seven of them and they catch me
on one I'll only get two years I'll be
out in a couple months that's [__] up
yeah good behavior yeah and then he's
out and he does the [__] again that's
why you got to be on crime they don't
learn some of these fcking depends on
what kind of crime it is when we're
talking about like violent crime like
this um yeah you got to be hard on all
crime they made it legal to steal under
under $800 worth of stuff basically in
some of these cities so seven or eight
20 guys will link up on
[__] [__] social media and all
agree to [__] rans sack the same
store at the same time and they'll go in
and steal each one of them will steal
$800 worth the [__] and [__] puts
that B that business that store out of
business you know then they you know
it'll be a Target or something and
they'll just shut it down so you can
just you can't make everything legal
well no one's trying to do that to but
they did that I'm just saying that
violent crime um you know I'm not a big
advocate of the death penalty except in
super extreme cases where you're
absolutely sure that that's the
[__] that did it but any kind of
violent crime like this murder rape any
like any kind of assault like that um
you
can't you can't just give them like a
year or two years just you can't give
them some like [__] slap on the
wrist because they're probably just
going to do it again you know what I'm
saying I don't know like every case is
different so you got to like take things
on a casee by case basis but still I
have read about cases where and like you
said in the
70s particularly cases that were sexual
in nature rape um you know anything do a
child abuse or anything like that I feel
like they didn't really take it as
seriously Bryce says he agrees you got
to be hard on crime but not things like
smok and weed exactly [__] like that
like that that shouldn't even be illegal
to be
honest the idea of illegalizing drug use
is very anti-American through most of
American History you had what was called
the right to Bliss you had the right to
get high it's your body who are they to
tell you what you can't put in your body
if you want to be a [__] junkie
that's that's you doing what you want
with your own body State doesn't own
your body I mean as long as you're not
like driving cars and
operating under you intoxicated that
that can be a crime but you should be
able to get high all you [__] want
that's your yeah I don't have a problem
with that if a girl wants to sell her
body or a man wants to sell her body and
pro that's her body yeah I don't have a
problem with that either State like I
said as long as nobody's forcing them
into it then if you want to make money
like that that's a different thing then
absolutely if I force someone else to do
it that's not the same thing yeah that's
a different that's a tot that could that
could be a crime okay CU that's like
stealing yeah all right um or if you
have people who are underage getting
involved in this business that could be
a crime too because their their brains
are not fully developed to make this
decision yet yeah and really you know me
and Jen are in the adult
industry really even 18 years old in in
some ways I would a person is not fully
developed that's still kind of
questionable yeah I remember some of the
dumb [__] I did when I was in my early
20s you know what I mean you get some
kind of naive girl at 18 and she gets
involved in the porn industry it's going
to dominate the rest of her life it's
going to affect her ability to get
married and [__] it probably should be
more like 21 okay but the thing is is
they'll never do that because they can
draft a male yeah to become a soldier at
18 and go kill people and get himself
killed what's more dangerous I mean
they'd have to just change it to 21
across the board if they were going to
do that but they would never do that cuz
they want them 18 old boys in combat
because when you when you're 18 you're
[__] dumb they can tell you anything
and you go yeah that's right we're going
to [__] take care of this Mission
we'll make it and it's a suicide mission
or you're fighting a country that really
is no threat to your to your like okay
the War I was involved in [__] I was
in during the first Gulf War the that
was no threat to the United States that
was a threat to Rich guys trying to make
money here United States hasn't really
fought a war protecting its own country
its own borders in [__] centuries you
know probably Mexican-American war and
that was that was us taking [__] from
Mexico
uh probably the last thing you know the
Revolutionary War war of 1812 maybe that
was a war where you were defending
America the rest of it was all wars of
Empire Rich guys sending young guys out
to go get some kind of asset or resource
or protect some kind of investment that
they made over overseas that's all that
[__] is it's the ultimate form of
prostitution you're a young man pimping
your body out to old men not for sex but
for fighting fighting and [__] it's
been going on for thousands of years
prostitution is the oldest profession
soldiering is the second
oldest that's just I'm going to hook up
with you guys and we'll kill that
[__] elephant together and if we get
it done give me some of that meat it's
just another form of
that DVD Dragon said Tom's Island would
be nothing but motorcyle gyms Firearms
ranges and porn stars yeah pretty much
yeah Jim would be Center Center she'd be
the I was going to say I I didn't even
think that I'd be on
that' what do you need me for you got
all you got all this porn stars you
don't on what stage of development I was
in you know what I mean if we're talking
about me back in my 20s or 30s hell yeah
then yeah I wouldn't be invited I
wouldn't have known you I wouldn't have
known you like I said you still been
married back then to that other guy
that's
true Tammy says in the 70s
child abuse and domestic violence was
seen as a family's personal business y
that's absolutely true that's what I
mean and I feel like probably up
until maybe even into the 80s but
probably most of the 70s I feel like by
the time like the 80s came along like it
was kind of starting to change but I
feel like like dudes that like smack
their wives around and stuff like that
like people didn't really think there
was much wrong with that no they thought
something was wrong with I remember my
dad making comments of it and around his
other friends they thought that [__] was
[__] up but there wasn't you could do
that's what I mean it wasn't really cuz
they're like oh well that's their
business like you can't it's like there
wasn't any legal way to go hey you
stopped that you did it wasn't like that
which is dumb because it's just kind
like look if you went up to a random ass
person on the street and punched them in
the face then you'd go to jail why would
it be different just because you were
married to that person that's still
another person it was the thinking of
the time stupid as hell like well
they're a couple and that's their
business and we can't really get
involved in that that's I mean you're
still punching a person in the face you
would still go to jail if you did that
to a stranger so why would you not go to
jail if you did it to a person that you
were married to or a person in your
family right but still yeah but that's
but see that's another thing like what
if it's two guys and that was like your
friend and then you got in a fight and
you punched that dude in the face you'd
still go to jail yeah you know that guy
no no no no because you'd have to press
charges well yeah I know that but that's
true of everything MH like obviously if
nobody press charges nobody goes to jail
even remember that cop asked me if they
wanted to press charges on the dude that
was [__] with me in the a long time
ago and the drunk dude at
[__]
Denny's talking all that [__] oh that's
right I forgot all that cop says you
want me to arrest him press charge I
said no and he went back he says you're
lucky cuz I want to lock you up
that's he's just a drunk that's right I
forgot about that yeah called me Marilyn
Manson and [__] wasn't he like throwing
[__] at the windows or yeah he probably
got arrested later on anyway he was
drunk probably did but um yeah no I just
I just remember uh the attitudes of the
time another thing is granted there's
heal a test when we went to high school
it was known that some of the teachers
were having affairs with some of the
students yeah that happened when I was
in in high school now they were tended
to be they tended to be seniors and the
teachers tended to be like people in
their 30s maybe early 30s nobody said
anything they didn't even think anything
all that it was kind of like woohoo wow
they okay you know what I mean t he we
didn't think it was a big
deal the attitudes were very different
back then yeah High Desert says it may
be hard to imagine now but if a kid
showed up to school with bruises all
over it was no big deal and then Tammy
said I live through it teachers did
nothing cops called to the house saw my
mom bleeding and they did nothing yeah
and another thing is is that it wasn't
just uh male
teachers quote unquote taking advantage
of of the females it was female teachers
dating male students
too they they did it
both and then Bryce said I think people
thought a man had a right to discipline
his wife yeah that seemed like a pretty
prevalent attitude like I said here
probably up until the
70s from what I remember I it started to
change after that from what I remember
my dad and his friends talking about it
they couldn't do they they were under
the impression that they couldn't do
anything she had to complain about it
she had to go to the police herself yeah
that was the thinging and even then I
feel like in the 60s or 70s if a woman
had gone to police and said hey my
husband's beating me up they would have
just said oh well what' you do wrong
then you know what I mean I don't think
so well I guess it would depend I mean
it depend where you were well this was
happening in California yeah in the 70s
cuz I remember my dad and one of his
work buddies knew this guy and they
thought he was a [__] yeah well
that's good because he was a [__]
yeah I don't know if he was beaten her
but he was you
know like verbally abusive and
aggressive towards her you know what I
mean he's like real domineering type
holy crap like that guy that was on the
was on Kitchen Nightmares last night it
was like
that yeah we were watching the new
Kitchen Nightmares last night cuz he
Gordon Ramsey has a new Kitchen
Nightmares if you didn't know I've been
watching it on
Hulu um but yeah so somebody mentioned
this [__] earlier here's another
suspect that a lot of people um think is
kind of one of the top suspects this guy
uh is named Christopher
Bush now Christopher Bush as ganthers I
believe mentioned before was the son of
GM executive Harold Le Bush so he's very
wealthy comes from a very wealthy
family now Chris Bush had actually been
in police custody uh not too long before
um Timothy King was abducted um for
suspect he was suspected to be involved
in uh Kitty prawns so there we go now
much like Epstein this [__]
supposedly committed suicide in November
of
1978 thing about the suicide though he
was wasn't in jail I believe it was in
his house they found him dead in his
house um he'd been shot between the eyes
no gunshot residue on his hands no blood
spatter uh and there were four shell
casings found in the room even though I
believe there was only one shot in his
head um also found like all kind of
wrapped up in his sheets like all his
arms were like all wrapped up like that
yeah so um also allegedly there were
some Like Blood Stained ligatures found
in his apartment as though he'd been TI
up uh so but no body no the body was
right there body was okay yeah obviously
okay cuz I just said he I was I was
paying attention to other things at the
time okay i' been drinking too but his
body was there okay yeah it like I said
it was wrapped up in a sheet he'd been
shot in the head right between the eyes
yeah the difference is is that with the
Epstein
story in general they're saying that he
died and they came in to rescue him and
he died from killing himself
I don't think he's dead at all I think
he's alive that'd be a very easy way to
have a mission and those that those were
all contractors intelligence agency
contractors they had it all planned out
with
the guards that were on duty at that
time to sabotage
cameras they're going to give him
payoffs and they went in there and they
got estein out is what they did I don't
think he died at all he pretended to be
dead they put him on the G and got it
out then they faked the whole autopsy
thing I never saw his body you see any
pictures of his body why would I look
for pictures because they're not there
he's out he's free somewhere they went
there and rescued their own well this
guy they definitely found him dead but
they said it was suicide but most people
are kind of like n didn't really look
that much like a suicide looked like a
murder looked like he got like hit um
also in his apartment where they found
him there was a drawing which I've seen
of a boy screaming that looked very much
like Mark steans the first victim even
had like a little parka hood on and
everything like that like steans was
wearing when they when he got uh taken
also interestingly Christopher Bush
drove a blue Vega which might have been
mistaken for a gremlin because they look
very similar so there was that too like
I said he's dead so they're not really
sure but there is kind of like a
whole conspiracy theory that because he
was from a wealthy family that the cops
were kind of like covering up for him or
that there were maybe other PDF files
allegedly in the cops or you know that
were covering for him in some fashion
High Desert [__] he put He says
nobody believed that the PDF files were
real yeah they're
real well yeah I do kind of feel like
maybe people didn't really
realize see that's why I'm saying like I
think it's better nowadays that
everybody's like you know everybody
talks about like now everybody knows
everything about everything and like
there's no mystery about anything
anymore but in a way I kind of feel like
that's better you know yeah I think
that's better it's there's more of that
you know that's going on and there's
been a long history going back to the
1930s of intelligence agencies using
that that angle starting off in Germany
yeah so yeah it
exists yeah I'm just saying talk about a
Code of Silence I think most people
didn't think about it yeah you got a
code of viot another thing that
intelligence agencies do is that they
they penetrate Cults and they'll take
over a cult and use the cult as a
tool some reason they didn't do it
didn't do it to Scientology Scientology
would have been a good one to take
over um Argentina took over a damn
German cult where they were trying to
damn keep kids from going through
puberty and they were also using that
that same cult as the secret place to do
interrogations and and tortures and
stuff they were using these German
civilians that they basically made
sausage over there in Germany to do it
for them and in a cult compound so it's
not just the US it's just intelligence
agencies in
general
penetrating a [__] coven or a network
of PDF files is is power would be a very
powerful thing so you now have access to
all these very rich PDF files that can
promote one another get each other in
position and now you can run all of them
on remote
control CU if they don't obey you they
don't obey the organization you can out
them a lot of mental leverage everything
all those all those Intel agencies use
leverage on
people murder Hornet said drunk driving
wasn't a big thing back in the day oh no
it absolutely wasn't yeah a lot of
people just they didn't think anything
about it yeah he also says I had a
female special ed teacher I would hang
out with during break she would talk sex
and even went to to her house but
nothing ever happened so you know who
was this what did he say murder Hornet
said that yeah um all right so yeah like
said de didn't kill himself I've isn't
dead I believe he's
alive yeah okay qu yeah I need my I need
more all right yeah yeah because we got
bought some orange juice today and Mar
vodka but yeah so Christopher Bush a lot
of people do like him as a suspect but
like I said he's dead in a suicide which
you'd think if they wanted it to make it
look like a suicide they would have done
a better job than that that's all I'm
saying now Barry King who was the uh
father of Timothy King like I said he
kind of spent the remainder of his life
up until he died in 2020 um basically
trying to catch the [__] that
did this and also you know raising money
for the Timothy King fund which helped
other abuse children now he actually
filed I don't even remember how many
Freedom of Information acts uh you know
things that he filed but he got like
3500 pages of information like about the
case and he actually him and his sister
like both worked on it and they released
like a lot of it to the public they also
made a documentary which was called
Decades of Deceit and they were
basically like [__] all over the
cops and the prosecutors um for just not
doing the investigation to the best of
their ability um and saying that they
didn't really communicate with the
families all that well and that um that
they didn't really listen when the
family came up with like specific leads
like they were kind of like half asked
about investigating them so they made a
thing like uh making those allegations
also now in 2012 because like I said
they're still kind of they're still
working on this case because obviously
they don't know who it is so it's still
an open investigation so in 2012 uh
thank you very much Victor just got hair
start
over thank you Mr Garcia I mean we're
still we're still talking about the [__]
so it's fine it's not that late it's
well it's 9:30 that's all right
yeah that's good yeah I like it with
orange juice the best yeah orange juice
orange juice made Victor gay you know
yeah probably yeah it made him gay did
it Victor thank you very much Victor we
really appreciate that's how good it
is that's how good orange juice is
orange juice will make you gay whoops oh
well but yeah so yeah so in 2012 they
did more DNA tests and remember the hair
that I said that they found in that SLO
dude's car that wasn't his um so the
hairs that they found in his car like I
said had been found on Mark steans and
Timothy King's body so those were a
match they came from the same man but
they didn't know who it was at that time
what he said Hawaiian punch made him
gay which makes me think I just bought
that damn Publix Punch Yeah public you
go to Publix Publix [__] fruit punch
yeah get it you get it where you get the
the soda man it's [__] great it's
kind of like Hawaiian Punch but it's
slight it's Tiki Punch Yeah it's
slightly carbonated that shit's good
good with rum or vodka I got some of it
in my little mini fridge right up here
the office fridge yeah yeah we got like
a whole bunch of so I understand how sod
I understand how punch could make you
gay I understand might work on might
work on you someday no I'm pass I pass
the window it has to be a certain
age where where punch could flip you
yeah it's like around nine or 10 that's
that's could happen
Okay um but yeah so as I mentioned this
hair came from the same dude but they're
not entirely sure who that is it's not
Sloan's hair but obviously it was
somebody that was in the car either
someone that was in the car with him or
somebody that he loaned the car to at
some
point so here's another suspect named
James gunels and he was interviewed in
2012 uh you know kind of you know after
they discovered who he was and we're at
asking him about this case and he said
he absolutely did not do it however um a
hair that was found on Christine uh
melik's body is a mitochondrial DNA
match to
him now the reason that they haven't
arrested him I I don't know how much you
guys know about DNA probably a lot
mitochondrial DNA and nuclear DNA are
two different things so nuclear DNA if
you get a match there um the odds of
that [__] not being you is is like 1 in
700 trillion or 70 trillion or something
like that it ridiculous they're like
okay [__] it was you that's your DNA
yeah however if it's just mitochondrial
DNA uh the odds there are more like one
in
150 so it could be him or it could be
any one of his male lineage like on his
mom's side so that's not enough to
arrest somebody because it could be like
a lot of people it could be like a
relative of his you know what I'm saying
like a male relative
so even though his hair does match it's
not a good enough match for them to uh
arrest him they don't have enough uh and
he basically says and this is a quote
from him he says I'm not guilty uh there
it is there but at the same time I know
how the state police twist words to
their advantage my heart goes out to
those families it really really does I
don't feel that they were serve Justice
through any of this did he do it it does
seem weird that his hair was there but
like I said only one in 150 that's not
enough like I said if it was nuclear DNA
then they'd be like yeah that's the
[__] but I don't know it just
seems like maybe not now I should note
too that he was only 16 years old when
the killings took
place so they thought if he was indeed
involved then he might have been either
just like part of the group that was
doing the killings or that he was used
as a lure because one thing that they
they said remember how I said earlier
they thought the killer was somebody
that like an adult that kids wouldn't
have a reason to distrust like a teacher
or a cop or something another theory
that they floated was that maybe it was
another kid um which sounds far-fetched
but not really because didn't Dean Coral
did that [__] where he had another kid
who was like a teenager um for that very
reason because he knew that a teenager
would come with another teenager when he
wouldn't go with an adult man so they
have speculated and this is all
completely specul
um you know I'm not making any
accusations or anything but I'm saying
people have speculated that if guns was
involved you know when he was 16 it
might have been as a lore like he was
sent out to hey go get that guy to that
kid to come over here because they
wouldn't necessarily distrust a teenager
and that Dean Coral guy I think he I
think he paid
bounties yeah reach kid and I think it
was under $100 if I remember correctly
it was short
Change and sometimes just things like
weed giving him weed yeah he would like
pay like give him money or drugs or
something like that to like go get and
the kid like and the kid knew what was
he was a teenager but he knew what was
going on oh yeah he watched some of it
happen he watched some of it happen it's
a [__] up case so I'm just saying that
even though it does sound far-fetched
that like a 16-year-old would be
involved in something like this not
really because it has happened before
but like I said this is all completely
speculative they don't really know and
like I said maybe that's not even his
hair it does seem weird that it's a
mitochondrial DNA match but it's not a
close enough DNA match for them to be
certain that he had anything to do with
it but that was just like some
speculation that they had about
that um they've also speculated that
James and maybe his brother might have
also been groomed or sexually abused by
the members of this PDF file ring like
Christopher Bush and some of the others
so and then you know they kind of got
into it as well or you know I don't
really know or they were forced into
recruiting kids for it who knows there's
all kind of [__] up that [__] [__]
that could
happen now here's this other guy and
this is kind of out there but I just
thought I'd bring this up so here's this
whole situation of this person who then
this is a pseudonym but their pseudonym
is Jeff Ganon now this happened in
2005 so this is a dude who like I said
he's a pseudonym they don't really know
who he is uh really but he um came
forward to the authorities and said that
back in
1977 he had an
acquaintance who would drive him around
and would take him to these buildings
that had something to do with the crimes
and also um told him that like Satanic
rituals were going on there like I said
this is very satanic Panic going on here
and he um he kind of like said some of
the same stuff that was said in the
letter that I talked about earlier like
that Allen said that he was like the
satto masochistic slave of this dude
named Frank or whatever so he was kind
of like saying some of that same [__]
about that um and he actually asked the
cops if he could see that letter but
they wouldn't let him see
it now so this guy in 2010 they just
like I said they just call him Jeff I
don't know what his real name is so he
gives an interview to investigators in
Oakland County and he says that he has
evidence you know having to do with this
investigation and he said that um so
there was this whole thing where he
tried to I don't know like this guy he
seemed to be
suggesting that whoever the killer or
killers were and he seemed to be
implying that it was like a ring which
they think probably it was kind of like
a ring that was involved but he seemed
to think that it was something to do
with ritual killings and that they
actually had killed between 11 and 16
children not not just for and that he
killed them and that they killed them on
dates that were like important to like a
cult calendars or whatever the thing
about this guy though is that as it went
on like they kind of looked into some of
his [__] it seemed like but he said that
I have all of these photos and I have
all of this evidence and all of this
other stuff and I'll give it to you if
you know what I mean so he had like all
of these stipulations for like how like
why when he was going to give him the
evidence like they had to give him some
[__] first um like he G he gave the
information some of the information to
like the media but he remained Anonymous
and that's what he was saying when he
was saying oh there's all these Wiccan
or satanic human sacrific just like
wiccans don't Human Sacrifice people but
you know what I mean maybe he didn't
know what he was talking about
overweight lesbians I mean well I mean
yeah well wiccans they're like pretty
chill yeah they're not so they're
they're not sacrificing people that's
not a wicked thing um no you get in big
trouble in Wicked if you do that kind of
[__] it's against the rules so uh so
yeah and even a lot of that satanic we
did a whole show about satanic Panic we
should I think did we do a revisit on it
we could always do another one I mean I
mean I think we've done two there's a
plethora of [__] topics to talk about
there really are because it was just
like such a broad wide Bry is gone yeah
the always has to be some con stanic
Rich that's what I mean it's like
somebody always brings that up it was a
meme of it of the day it was everything
was like Satanist like every time
somebody was murdered in like a
particularly gruesome way everybody's
like oh it's Satanist yeah now DVD
Dragon brings up the fact that fruit PCH
is uh [__] either makes you gay or
very [__] susceptible what do he say
makes you very easy to influ punch will
make you gay or very easy to influence
it's the MK Ultra of fruit juices EXA
exactly and it's because it has that
Island flavor it's what it is oh I
didn't make that connection but there
you go Island flavor Islands man full of
PD files you know they do you go there
you go there what happens on that island
stays on that island and all those
islands are like
that hell yeah look at Jamaica they got
all the damn white women going down
there to go take [__] to to get
Knocked Up by these [__] Jamaican
smooth ass Jamaican dudes that [__]
work off the beaches and [__] you know
what I mean it's just it's a lot of sex
happening on those islands so so them
islands are gay sex Island yeah look at
Fire Island if you're going to talk
about gay gay [__] Fire Island Don't
Know Anything could happen
so fruit punch man it's
dangerous uh it takes it's a gateway
drug it's a
Gateway you have to be fully formed in
your sexual tastes before you can really
drink fruit punch uh especially Tiki
punch with confidence okay you're going
to be putting your you're going to be
putting your preferences in Jeopardy you
might [__] take some of that [__] and
all of a sudden you go oh man look at
that dude's ass M you never know it
could
happen that that looked pretty genuine
Tom you were really checking out at
there
damn look at that b you can bounce a
quarter out you can bounce a quarter out
that but yeah so this guy I don't know I
I kind of feel like maybe he's crazy or
maybe he's just trying to get money
because after he told the the
journalists all this stuff about you
know human sacrifices on these dates on
the Pagan calendar and all that kind of
stuff um he tried to one he tried to
file a
lawsuit um you know there was like a
lawsuit filed against the Oakland County
authorities for $100
million um you know because of
mishandling the investigation uh you
know they were saying there was a
conspiracy and coverups and all this
other kind of [__] and then um this
other guy tried to get that guy's like
he was essentially trying to sell it for
like $1,500 donations like I have this
all of this evidence you guys but you
have to give me $1,500 before I give it
to you and I was just kind of like n you
know cuz well the thing about it was
like the guy actually went to the mother
of one of the victims and was trying to
like get some [__] and like you know
trying to get on her good side so he get
more into the investigation but I don't
know it to me it seems
like I said I'm not I definitely do
think well you know they know provably
that there were PDF file rings in this
area at this time because they caught a
bunch of them um so I definitely don't
think it's outlandish to say that a PDF
file ring was not responsible for these
four particular murders or like somebody
that was in maybe they were just acting
of their own valtion but they were
Associates of those people um but at
anytime the [__] goes into like Satanic
ritual I'm always like super skeptical
of that I'm not saying it doesn't happen
but it's like super super super rare and
it really does seem like around this
time period this is slightly early but
there was kind of some [__] going on in
the 70s and 80s like I said any kind of
murder that had any kind of like strange
little detail even if it was like a
total stretch or a total reach like oh
my God we found a copy of the
Necronomicon like in the house or
something like that satanic you know
what I mean it it was like that it was
that bad so if if you weren't there so
so I I don't know so so I kind of look a
scance at this kind of [__] like like I
said I'm not saying that this that these
four murders in particular and maybe
some of the other ones which I'm going
to talk about in a minute because there
are some that are maybe related and
they're not entirely sure and I'm not
saying that there's not more murders
than uh than than are you know usually
part of this series because I think
there probably were just for that seems
like I kind of feel like this person
person or persons probably did more than
that and maybe they just didn't link
them you know what I'm saying so that's
why there's like I said I'll get into
talking about some other ones that are
possibly linked like in a minute but
that's the thing I this dude this whole
Jeff situation I don't know again it's
just kind of like the whole Allan Frank
letter with the St of masochistic
slave is it impossible you know no it
you know obviously it could happen but
it just seems unlikely just seems
unlikely so at this point um there's
been a couple documentaries about this
there's actually if you want to watch it
I think you can still watch it like on
their website but um what's it called
click on Detroit or whatever that
website they did like a five part series
I think it's on YouTube also I think
it's like five hours like it's so it's
like a five-part series about this case
the investigation and it goes a lot into
I didn't watch all five hours but I
watched like a like an hourong summary
of like all the stuff with clips from it
and everything cuz I didn't have time to
watch the whole thing but um but yeah
yeah but that's on YouTube if you want
to watch that because they delve a lot
more into the North Fox Island [__] and
all that other kind of stuff um and I
think like investigation discovery also
did a 4-Hour documentary about this case
as well um so yeah so there are some
other let's talk about like before we
wrap up the topic we'll talk about a few
other murders similar murders that
happen around this time period that they
think might be related possibly they
know those four are just because you
know of various details about
particularly like the dog hair and
things like that but these ones are
possible so this one happened a little
bit earlier this was a an older girl she
was 17 years old her name was Donna
Sarah this was September 29th
1972 that was only three days after I
was born actually uh she was actually
hitchhiking to a beach uh after school
this was in makum County Michigan
uh so and then she disappeared now her
body was found uh in a creek laying face
down on October 20th
1972 um now she had been uh like kept
captive and uh drugged for several days
she was uh strangled and her murder is
unsolved to this day they think this
might be related maybe not not where did
they find her again uh it was in uh Ray
Township is where they found her body
just along the side the road uh yeah 27
Mile Road that's where they found her
yeah 27 Mile and she had been kept for
several days same as the no damage on
her um not that I know she was but she
was strangled though but she was older
she was 17 so a little bit older than
the victim profile or the the other four
but not what you know I don't I don't
know if these are going to be because I
kind of feel like the four canonical
murders that's like more a PDF file
thing whereas this is more like a your
classic serial killer thing where it's
kind of like
who okay who like uh how did she come up
missing did it say she just disappeared
while while hitchhiking while
hitchhiking yeah which happened a lot in
the 70s who was she did I mean in terms
of like as a person she was just from
that area yeah just a regular girl a
regular 17-year old girl all right high
school girl that could be anything
that's what I mean but you know um just
a couple of things the fact of her being
held captive uh for several days there
was like some other similarities but
yeah the people holding her captive
might it might have been people she knew
you don't know she might have been
partying with some yeah that's what I'm
saying but I'm taking a lot of drugs
party with them for a few
days and uh then they killed her over
something and then dumped her body you
don't know may had nothing to do with
serial
killing you know what I mean well maybe
killing her maybe they killed her by
accident or an argument came you know
broke out something like that you don't
know right because usually if it was a
serial killer it' be repeat you'd be a
bunch of them well and like I said um I
think a lot of times too is that if
there are murders in the same area that
have
similarities obviously they're going to
link those because you know
realistically how many you know it
depends obviously on what area it is
what your crime statistics are but
realistically in an area like this how
many murders do you see annually let's
say that so if you see two murders that
are kind of different but have a lot of
similari you're going to like assume
that maybe they're connected because
what are the odds that there's two
[__] running around doing this
[__] you know what I mean depending on
where it is if it's a bigger city then
like obviously that's not weird yeah but
I mean that does s that's a very
suspicious death but for all you know
that was her ex-boyfriend yeah you never
know you don't know you never know right
so another one that is um kind of
suspected to be part of the same series
was a 13-year-old girl named Janet uh or
Janie Allen now she actually went Miss
missing August 8th
1976 uh she was also hitchhiking uh
between Pontiac and Royal Oak and that's
in Oakland County Michigan uh she was
later found like a few days I believe it
was three days later um floating in a
river in Ohio on August 11th uh so that
was about 200 miles away from where she
disappeared just because she was last
seen hitchhiking that doesn't mean the
guy who gave her the ride killed her she
might have got where she was going and
well that's another thing but there but
that's always the best place to start
because you're the last person that's
seen her alive as far as anyone knows
everybody knows so that's where you got
to start but yeah I mean she might have
been picked up been taken five miles
down the road got dropped off and some
other [__] picked her up but
nobody saw her you know what I mean to
her destination and the dude had her
destination killed her yeah there's a
million there's a million possib a
million possibilities yeah that dude
killed her in an argument or something
but yeah so they found her 200 miles
away in a river um her wrist had been
tied behind her back with her like her
t-shirt had been torn up and they tied
her hands behind her back with that um
they weren't actually able to tell if
she'd been sexually assaulted because
her body was so decomposed when they
found
her um but she was dead before she was
thrown in the water uh her cause of
death though was carbon monoxide
poisoning which is odd left her in a
garage and G yeah I guess so so that's
kind of [__] up but yeah sounds like
they tied her up yeah so she was much
younger she was 13 like I said then we
also have a be a cowardly way of doing
it that's pretty [__] up you can't do
it with your own hands so you're going
to put her in a damn
garage turn the car off like in a gas
chamber like a gas chamber yeah that's
[__] up or you might you might have
had a damn pipe coming off of off the
tailpipe onto a bag around her head
that's another way you could do
it yeah yeah gaster to death that's
messed
up um you that's a [__] cowardly [__]
you know [__] nasty [__] that's
like something BTK would do actually
yeah that sounds like some [__] he would
do yeah he would think that that would
be real cool to see that happen oh I
just wanted to see it you know he's like
that you know want to see what would
happen that dude is like yeah like I
said I've said this before like Sophie
gave me a book about him um that was
like all um what the hell is that
woman's name that's she's like a
criminologist or something she's written
like a zillion books and I can see her
face and I just can't think of her name
I'll think Katherine Katherine ramsland
ramsland and she um corresponded with
BTK for many years and so she wrote a
book about you know and she put like a
lot of the stuff from his letters in
there and like that dude's thought
processes are just [__] bizarre yeah
like reading that I was just like
weirded out by the whole but that
totally sounds like that sounds like the
kind of [__] that he would do like CU he
would want to see that I don't know man
like I said everybody's got sexual
fantasies everyone's got weird sexual
fantasies they probably don't want to
tell other people about
but I can very safely say that I've
never had a fantasy about anything like
that you know it's weird man
BTK his fantasies were about how people
were dying and what they were thinking
and he' dress up like the female victim
and put himself in bondage and pretend
like he was dying so he could feel like
what it was like it just weird dude and
be jerking it while that was happening
evidently trying to take pictures of
it and that's some unusual [__] man it
is unusual like I said I would not have
a problem with him you know dressing and
drag tying himself up putting himself in
a hole like jerk like there's nothing
wrong with that but the fact that he was
also doing that to other people yeah you
know like I said if he' just been doing
that and wasn't a murderer I think
people have been like yeah it's kind of
weird but like whatever I think the
murder started first he did some girl
and then he wanted see what it felt like
he thought that was real hot he thought
it was hot that's the thing people don't
understand he thought that [__] was
really hot the way way they died and
what led up to it then he'd want to
experience it he you know yeah and he
said it's because he got tied up to a
tree when he's a little boy they're
playing Cowboys and Indians and he liked
it and he got off on it yeah he rocked
up which like I said that's not weird
because a lot of people get into like a
lot of people are into like being tied
up or you know that's there's nothing
weird about that it's pretty common it's
kind of weird though I mean it's a
pretty common Kink though is what I'm
saying but you know but if he hadn't
killed anybody nobody would have thought
anything about it you know especially
nowadays people oh I like to be tied up
and like yawn I mean like I said that's
a pretty very that's a very comic Kink
yeah no one no one's even going to bat
an ey that was a huge that was his first
like sexual experience be tied up to a
tree by some kids
playing it was Cowboys in Indians was it
yeah yeah yeah and that's the thing and
I get why that's arousing I get
that I don't well no I'm well I get
because some people really like
completely surrendering control to
another person that's why and they think
that's that's very arousing for them and
like I said that's not weird it's like I
don't but but the fact that he just took
that and instead of just getting into
BDSM like a [__] normal person yeah
um other people had to die over it right
that's what I mean it's like why didn't
you just get into the BDSM Community
everything would have been fine and all
those people would still be alive yeah
so he's tying these women up and then
eventually strangling them everyone
would have been consenting like everyone
would have tied you could have been tied
up and like to your heart he thinks it's
hot as hell he thinks man that [__] was
so [__] sexy that's just so weird
Tammy says my sexual fantasy is seeing
Tom getting pegged that would be
hot we're never gonna we're never that's
[__] funny We're Never Gonna Let You
it down Tom they're going to have to
raise that money yeah he want yeah we
had some in there just saying that stop
St the show do a 20-minute Flex section
I'm [__] getting all this they trying
to get me to thirst trap like we're
doing we're doing shows about child
killers and you really want to like do
try try to thirst trap on these on I
thirst trapped last time I was here
Bryce paid me for the thirst trap yeah
yeah show them my underwear and [__]
that was during that was not during the
show though that was during uh well that
was on the Sidetrack on srack show I
think yeah wasn't it no I can't remember
started talking about my underwear
they're all kind of run together a
famous underwear you're famous under
you're $40 underwear yeah I don't know
if that pair was $40 but some yeah it
was 35 okay you're $35 underwear but uh
but yeah so okay let me let me talk
about these last few possibly related
victims so here was another uh
12-year-old this was another little girl
uh Kim King now she actually uh
disappeared from Warren Michigan this
was in September of
1979 she had actually been staying over
like sleeping over at a friend's house
and then called her sister sister at
11:00 at night and said hey I snuck out
of my friend's house and I'm like at a
phone booth so I guess she wanted her
sister to come get her she's 12 yeah so
her sister was like hey why don't you go
inside the gas station or convenience
store wherever it is you are um however
uh Kim seemed to disappear after that uh
and has not been seen or heard from
sense so she completely disappeared um
police actually believe she was abducted
and they also believe that her
disappearance is perhaps tied to this
series because it was in the same area
but they never found the body nope she
has not been found I don't think it's
connected well like I said they probably
are privy to more information than we
are so um you know just from a brief
summary it's kind of hard to say because
they have a lot more information than we
do so they must have some reason for
thinking it's connected that's all I'm
saying cuz there was proba yeah maybe
yeah there were may they heard something
but it's messed up it it's always messed
up to me that it's like every time I do
a show about like a serial killer and
stuff and a lot of times they'll be like
well here are the victims that they know
for sure was the same killer and then
they'll be like oh and then there was
all these other ones that might be
related and I'm like all these other
ones if they're not related that's
[__] up because there was like you
know they're all unsolved so it's like
so these people were also murdered by
[__] by not even this [__] serial
killer by like some other random
[__] running around I think a
lot of these are actually one-offs they
might that's what I mean but that's
scary because you don't really know like
you know it's bad enough having one
serial killer running around killing
four five six seven eight people but
then you have all these other ones
killing like one here two there [__]
like that completely different birth in
serial killers are rare you kill in
series it's would that's very
unlikely the the more likely more
plausible scenario is the guy's
fantasizing about this
[__] then all of a sudden he has an
opportunity to make a move he sees the
Target that he's like oh yeah that's
what I
like he takes the target does it and
then feels guilt he's like I didn't like
that and then don't do it again that'd
be very
likely that didn't turn out the way I
thought that wasn't worth it too much
risk uh shouldn't have done that then
they don't do it again yeah that's
probably the most likely outcome yeah
because it's less likely the dude goes
oh I'm going to do that
again well that's the thing you do kind
of hear a lot about serial killers
because serial killers tend to do one
and then they escalate yeah you know
they build up to it you know they kill
animals they do other kind of [__] and
then they kill a person you got to kill
three and then you got to kill three to
become a serial killer yeah I think I
think most of these dudes that do this
do one and then they're like I ain't
doing that anymore I think that's what
happens I wonder now I just kind of
wonder if there's like some random ass
trucker just like going around the
highways and being like I just you know
what I'm going to I'm going to murder a
chick just to see what it's like and
then he does it and then it's just like
either it wasn't all that or it was too
much trouble or he didn't like it or
something and then he just doesn't do it
again but then he never gets caught yeah
I think that's and can you imagine
because like later on that dude could
like get married and have kids and like
and no one would ever know I think
there's lot that is horrifying I think I
think for every one serial killer you
catch I think there's 10 of those yeah
you might be right about that well like
I said cuz you do hear a lot about the
pathology of serial killers which like I
said it's in their nature to escalate
because you know they get off on it and
they they have to keep escalating the
[__] like to get off on it more because
it's not you know it becomes routine to
them so they have to keep upping the
stakes I guess but you never really hear
about just dudes that do it once or
twice and then stop yeah cuz they don't
get caught because they don't get
caught and maybe that's why there's so
many like [__] unsolved yeah I think
so I think there's 10 of for every one
serial killer I think there's 10 of
those ones that do it
once they do it and they go oh that's
not like I thought I didn't you know
that's not like I thought it was going
to be like I didn't like that I'm not
going to do that again that I think it's
that's what it does yeah because to be a
serial killer you definitely do have to
have a compulsion
yeah and I do definitely think that some
people that are murderers that would
murder a person don't necessarily have
the compuls that they would feel the
need to continue doing that well I think
they I think at first they do have the
compulsion then they do it and they and
then the experience was negative it
didn't satisfy them or dissatisfied them
or they didn't like it it wasn't as hot
as they thought it was and they going
man this is too risky and I feel bad for
that girl I should have never done that
just too late now though just gonna say
yeah well no it's not too late because
stop too late for her too late for her
but stopping is better than continuing
true all right so but I think for every
one serial kill there's probably 10 of
those well like I said that might be why
there's so many unsolved murders and why
it's so hard yeah and and I might take
away from the data and I get that
authorities do kind of want to link a
lot of crimes to serial killers in the
area because they think well how many
people could be running around just
killing random ass people yeah um you
know in this area in this time period
which you know there is some uh
legitimacy to that but like you said I
don't
know maybe nowadays they put more stock
in the fact that it's like maybe this
was just like a oneoff or a two off and
it's just somebody that does that just
stopped right cuz sometimes they do stop
sometimes they they don't stop by their
own valtion they go to jail yeah and
then they're in there for 10 years and
they change their taste change while
they're in there they they lose interest
in that they don't go back to it or they
would uh get killed yeah or uh move away
yeah I think they lose their job and
move away there's there's a bunch of
different reasons why there could be
only one or
two you know yeah and it might be only
one or two in that area they might have
moved away and done a couple more but
then got caught or killed right or went
to prison and then for life for
something unrelated or went to prison
for 20 years for some kind of sexual
assault they were never really
identified as a serial killer you know
there's a bunch of [__] that could
happen but I think a lot of these
dudes this
the guy that becomes a serial killer has
to has to fit certain criteria to get
that title this is the criteria made up
by the FBI and how they profiled them
they had to kill at least three the
motive has to be sexual all right that's
how you do most of those dudes never
that book that I read said most of those
dudes never get past kill one they're
either caught or they
stop yeah so there they
are yeah Bryce said I agree they have a
fantasy that gets too real for
them I think that's what happens yeah
whereas if you're a serial killer with
that kind of pathology then you do it
one time and you be like man that was
awesome I'm I'm going to up St next I
like that but it wasn't quite but it
wasn't quite good enough good enough I'm
going to do it again yeah yeah I'm I'm
going to do it better next time yeah
that's the guy that becomes the serial
killer the rest of they got to
constantly improve right right the other
ones most of them probably 10 to
one fall out you know in other words
they go no I can't do this and you don't
see him again which too bad they didn't
stop before killing a person you know
cuz I've never killed a
person um but yeah so here are a few
other ones that are kind
of uh tangential that may be related
because you know like I said similar
area similar uh
emmo so there was a girl named Laura
Wilson she's 16 and she went to a market
in Detroit a byright market uh on
November 10th
1972 now she was seen in the market she
did go in there and get her stuff and
everything but after she left uh she
disappeared now um later on some kids in
Wayne County found her dead body in the
bushes uh not that far from her house
she had been um raped and she had also
had her head smashed in with a
brick now um
they were trying to you know her case is
like kind of tentatively associated with
the Oakland County child killer case um
unfortunately a lot of the evidence uh
in this case was destroyed in the late
1970s for whatever reason I don't know
if it was on purpose or accidental but
she's another one that um that is her uh
murder is unsolved so they are kind of
trying to tie that one in as
well and there was also a case that
happened in February of 1977 this was a
10-year-old named Valerie bishop and she
was actually raped and stabbed um close
to an abandoned house uh not too far
from her own house uh which was on the
west side of Detroit um she had actually
gone as many of these children had she
just gone on an errand like she was
going to the store down the street like
to buy some milk like her mom sent her
down there and um basically they the
weird thing about it is that even though
this happened at the time that the
Oakland County child killer task force
was still active because like I said
they didn't disband until December of
1978 and this was February of 1977 um
for whatever reason they didn't
investigate this case in conjunction
with that even though it seems uh pretty
similar even though she was very clearly
raped um you know and she was a girl and
she was stabbed and not strangled um so
this might have been a different
perpetrator but it did seem like maybe
they should have looked into it now
somebody was charged with this uh later
on a 30-year-old named Moses Potter um
but was actually later released because
of lack of evidence uh nobody else has
ever been arrested for this crime and it
remains unsolved so they're not sure if
that one's related or not like I said
the mo is a little bit different victim
profile is similar and the way she was
taken the area and stuff like that was
similar but you know again it's a little
bit different so they don't know if it's
related or not might be a different
[__] but like I said that's
what's kind of scary there's like a lot
of the fucking' 70s man the [__] 70s
there were just Killers running around
[__] everywhere well it was a
sexually charged very permissive era no
social
media um no centralized information flow
so you could get you could move around
and get away with a lot of stuff oh yeah
um sexual Kinks were starting to get
kind of mainstream it's you know they
had weird uh BDSM magazines [__] had
detective story
magazines nobody really knew what fetish
was some odd dude could get a hold of
some detective magazine have pictures of
hot women tied up and fing do with a
knife over him you know I was talking
about some crime that happened yeah BTK
likes B AK like that and just like what
me and Bryce are saying he's [__] he
he he agreed with me too he sees that he
goes yeah that'd be really hot to do
that all right she he finds some pretty
chick and he tries to outlive this
fantasy you know what I mean but then he
kills her and he's like something didn't
go right like he sees the look in her
eye when that [__] happened and their
empathy happened he's like oh no I ain't
doing that again man [__] that [__]
she didn't think that [__] was hot at
all you know just that's how [__]
crazy yeah imagine that it would be like
yeah who' have thought that like being
stabbed wow I'm just really suddenly not
in the mood anymore yeah yeah you know
what I mean [__] so you never can't
tell what level of [__] craziness
these dudes are but going through that
they're like oh no I'm not going to do
that again that wasn't satisfying or
there wasn't any fear at all in them
that that might turn them off too says
oh man I did that for nothing they
didn't react she called me an [__]
yeah yeah so you know the fantasy what I
would do if I was I'm not going to do
that again it made me look bad I didn't
really feel good about it so I'm not
going to do it again they're probably
real simplon type guys or fantasy prone
guys I would imagine so then um after
the [__] goes down they just don't do it
anymore because it didn't give them what
they wanted and uh I think that's the
majority of them that's the majority of
them most of them don't become serial
killers it's only some of them that go
okay yeah that was pretty good but I can
make it better or that one yeah that
kind of gave me what I wanted if I Tred
it again it i' get better at it yeah
like they make a whole project right
yeah yeah yeah like well that's what BTK
called them he called them project right
but that's that's a small minority of
these guys that have these fantasies but
like I said it's still pretty scary yeah
serial killers uh you know in general
are pretty rare thankfully yeah but
these other type of dudes the second
Echelon if that's what you want to call
it um there's going to I'm sure that's
going to be like a lot more common and
that's like pretty scary to think about
yeah but you also got to remember this
is the
70s this is the era of leted gasoline I
really think it has a lot to do with it
leted gas yeah we've talked about that a
lot poisoning in the mind [__] does
weird things to the brain and it makes
you more aggressive it lowers
inhibitions too there was also
uh a lot of drugs and alcohol and it was
a time of change and [__] um uh uh
the 1950s the conservatism of the 1950s
was going away and people there was kind
of like a bunch of Liberation was
happening and when you have [__]
rampant Liber sexual re you know sexual
[__] Liberation you're also going to
have outliers that are freakies like
dudes that [__] want to do criminal
activity sexual criminal activity
they're going to be involved in that to
I'm going to take it to a betterer level
okay well if that's normal then I'm
going to do this I want to be on the
edge they're doing that yeah under the
influence of drugs alcohol and [__]
lead
poisoning and like we've said too like
the 60s and 70s most people didn't think
anything about one letting their kids
run around alone outside that's way we
grew up we were people ran around
hitchhiked yes they were just getting
random ass people's cars they didn't
think it's single thing about it now
like I said most of the time um it was
fine because but we only hear about like
the times when it wasn't fine most
people were cool most people are cool
that's what I'm saying yeah that's what
I'm saying like most people are cool but
it's like you never know you never know
you're putting yourself in danger
especially if you're a pretty young girl
you get into dude's cars and some of
these dudes are
[__] crazy you know like I said now
then you're going to run into a CR 95%
of the time the dude was probably fine
yeah gave you some weed dropped you off
where you wanted to go Kumbaya if you
ever saw the movie Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood where the girl from the
[__] Manson cult gets in the damn car
with the uh with Brad with Brad Pit and
she kind of [__] is trying to [__]
show her little kachoo too and you know
what I mean and [__] trying to get
him to go with her to the [__] Ranch
and [__] he turns her down that kind of
[__] happened back in the 70s you know
the [__] it was kind of like a time
of free love for some of these people
you know they were I remember it yeah it
seemed like it wasn't really that big of
deal no when we went to [__] Sequoia
National Park and went to Lake clarkco
and [__] there was [__] rampant
nudism going on with teenage girls and
adults and [__] just walking around no
big deal yeah no one really cares yeah
the park rangers had come over and
[__] hand out weed to my aunt and
[__] you know and [__] her friends
would be there they'd be [__] playing
guitar and [__] smoking weed these
are the park rangers they had
guns but they were cool it was just
normal yeah because we're out in the
woods we're in nature yeah and like I
said I feel like most of the time people
were just like that like most people
were just cool and chill and like I said
you could hit shik and it was fine but
it's just like you know sometimes right
that would take advantage of that
situation cuz they're like hey there's
14-year-old girls out there like
hitchhiking to get to their Grandma's
house or whatever like I said most of
the time it was probably fine they
probably did it all the time but until
that one time when it wasn't fine yeah
and it was the culture was different it
would have been no big deal to be in a
certain environment like say in
California or out in a [__] W Sequoia
National Park a bunch of girls and a
bunch of guys together and they're all
[__] drinking [__] granny Annie
Green Springs wine and [__] Soven up
which was the beginnings of the wine
cooler you had to make them yourself
wine girls to drink them up and they'd
be smoking weed and the park rangers
there it'd be nothing to see you know 14
15y old girl making out out with a guy
who was like 22 it's just this just the
way it was they didn't even think that
was a problem oh isn't that cute you
yeah yeah it definitely was different
time yeah it definitely was a different
time it didn't have the same standards
you had
today yeah now everybody be like like oh
hey hey she's you know there's kind of
an age difference there you're 22 she's
14 back then you know what I mean
[__] if if if you were men
menstruating you were [__] good to go
they didn't get they wouldn't even
[__] consult the law books and the
cops wouldn't press charges on that now
if she complained yeah they would but no
yeah it's kind of weird to think about
now because because now like I said any
dude that's 22 that wants to go after
like 14-year-old girls obviously that's
super sketchy yeah super sketchy yeah
that's illegal yeah and that would be
enforced today but it wasn't in the 70s
it really wasn't it really wasn't like I
said unless somebody like she complain
her or her parents complained yeah the
parents could complain that's yeah they
tended not to uh [__] ACC just that
was rare to bring that up because then
that's then you're telling everybody
that your your daughter is sleeping with
[__] older guys so there's always
backlash to [__] you know what I mean
like oh her you
know well and the times well and yet
that's another thing too is that you
know if everybody knows your 14-year-old
daughter is doing then like you know you
get the [__] tag yeah yeah yeah but you
know was kind of like hippie days you
know a lot of people wore hippie type
clothing and it was just uh it was sex
positivity which I'm all for but not to
that extent I mean there has to be
limits right there has they weren't
raised with any limits like that they
didn't think they you know they in Most
states the age of consent probably was
14 I mean yeah I grew up in the 70s too
I mean I was a kid but I remember a lot
of this stuff going
on and it it really did seem like a lot
more per missive like I might you know
my family weren't like that but um you
know my family were just very middle of
the road like they weren't conservative
at all but they weren't like super hey
let's walk around naked in front of the
children like they weren't like that you
know what I mean it was just kind of
normal so but there was some of that
going on yeah um which again I think is
a little bit weird but you know
California was like that big time
especially around those Parks it was
basically nudism and going back to the
Wild and Going Back To Nature and it was
children teenagers and adults [__]
walking around nude parts around the
beaches and it was just like it wasn't
really sexualized you know which like I
said I kind of
get I kind of get the um the logic
behind that they were trying to
demystify it you know yeah which is
actually like I think that's a good idea
yeah because I think if you make too
much out of it it's just like you know
it's a body everybody's got a body and
if you overly sexualize them then
obviously that that's problems but you
know it's I don't know there's kind of
like a a gray area there I guess yeah
but also uh you know kids drank alcohol
I drank it yeah I drank it all the time
now I didn't become an alcoholic or
anything I didn't really start [__]
pounding down the liquor to my Army
times but then I didn't even become an
alcoholic there there's not enough time
you know what I mean you got to [__]
work well there are arguments too about
like going uh like Europe or like a more
Europe
like like you know kids there I don't
know about nowaday but like kids you
know back then you know they would just
be given wine with dinner like the
adults would and so they didn't tend to
become alcoholics later on because it
wasn't deal yeah it wasn't taboo they
they' been drinking it like little bits
of it their whole life so it wasn't so o
I'm rebelling you know what I mean it
wasn't anything like that I'd be
drinking wine coolers with all my aunt
my aunts and [__] all their little
[__] girlfriends and [__] and at the
time my aunts were in their 20s or teens
so you know when you think of Aunt you
think of old lady no they were like 20s
and teens yeah so you know back in those
days I didn't think there was anything
of it didn't I didn't really think about
it I don't think a lot of people did
yeah like I said the only reason we
think about it now is because in
hindsight we know that like a lot of bad
[__] happened to like some people back
then but like I said most of the time
takes a couple bad apples in an
environment like that and then it just
kind of ruins it cuz I kind of feel like
everybody was having a good time until
these [__]
but you did have like these
[__] going and particular in
this area cuz look when they were just
doing this investigation into this one
case these four murders they uncovered
like what like two separate P PDF file
Rings yeah they in the same area yeah
now Victor Victor said that wine coolers
made him gay okay yeah so which one is
it Victor was it the was it the was it
the punch or was wi was it Z zema wait
zema is not a wine cooler is it Z what
the [__] was zema zema was a uh was it a
malt it was a malt liquor thing it was a
malt beverage yeah kind of like
synthetic beer it's actually pretty good
but it tasted like Sprite I think I had
it one time because man in the in the
90s or whenever that came out yeah they
they did an aggressive advertising
campaign that [__] was everywhere so I
said okay I'm going to see what the [__]
this I was in the Army the time I was in
a club with all my [__] friends my
guys in my units probably about six of
us and we were in downtown [__] ten
one of one of the Tennessee Nashville we
were in
Nashville and [__] I saw that [__]
zema sitting there in that little
[__] glass refrigerator that they had
behind the bar and I I remember that
those commercials cuz they were
everywhere yeah and I said let me try I
said what is this Dem they tried to
explain it to me and I said let me try
one like what the [__] does that mean
just give me one try one so I tried I
took one and I drink I drink about
halfway and one of my friends saw me
drinking that [__] he took it from me
and threw that [__] don't let anybody
see you drink [__] garbage men don't
drink that get the [__] some [__]
get some [__]
beer that's a girl's
drink yeah never drink the [__] again
Victor said zema with a Jolly Rancher in
it made me gay yeah I remember that was
the big thing maybe my friends may have
saved me zema could have turned me gay
for all I know a yeah and they be
hanging out with you
yeah maybe you'd let me Peg you
though Sam's going
yeah you know you know I had to finagle
that into the
conversation [__] women man women in
their fantasies aren't we the worst yeah
a you love me shut up yeah yeah see a
nice hat remember that weird yeah that
we yeah he had to do with the Fedora and
[__] Greek I can't like thinking about
it now with the mustache seemed like
every [__] five minutes it was a zema
commercial on that [__] was like that
was some cultural saturation they had
going on I don't know how much money
they spent well it wasn't just them man
[__] CT 45 malt liquor was [__]
they were trying to sell that too but I
don't remember those commercials as much
I just remember like [__] zema being
everywhere like when it first started I
remember the [__] Co 45 and the
bull there's a bunch of them [__] s
eyeses say all the malt Liquors Tammy
said buy a case of Zema
yeah I show yeah we should buy a case
you can drink it on the show yeah I
remember it because I when I drank it I
was like well it's fine it's inoffensive
yeah not great but it wasn't anything
spectacular is there any more on this
case no that's it yeah I finished it I
finished okay so we can widen down but
uh no you know [__] we
reviewed uh Mal liquor here
recently I hadn't had it since I was in
the barracks in the Army brothers were
drinking [__] Malt
Liquor I remember it being good so we
went and got some yeah that's just real
good yeah I was actually surprised it's
like for the money man you want to go
for Mal liquor if you don't have much
money you go for malt liquor and uh I
researched the damn history of Mal
liquor that was supposed to be upscale
beer they were selling trying to sell it
to white people white people wouldn't
buy it black people bought it though so
then the company started to shift and
change their um [__] Target marketing
to the African-American Community but
they were right that was a [__]
better quality beer they said that it
was it's a very good quality beer you
get a lot for your money it does taste
really good yeah it's especially
especially for what you paid I was
surprised yeah I was expecting it to
kind of taste like ass but it was
actually thick and real it was actually
pretty good and uh it's also has a
higher alcohol content so it's more bank
for which is always a plus but it was it
was originally meant to be a high-end
high power beer for the [__] white
upper middle class that's what they were
targeting it just didn't quite work
whoops it didn't quite work they they
they white people kind of rejected it
they didn't like the T this was the
marketing from the 60s in the
70s later on [__] uh when when uh I
think it was Colt 45 came out they had
Billy D Williams as a spokesman and I
that I really remembered those
commercials I [__] love Billy de [__]
I Associated it with Star Wars you
know [__] Lando's [__] drinking
that [__] then I'm gonna drink that [__]
damn I remember that but I was too young
at that time but when I saw [__] Cole
45 I was thinking the [__] is Billy de
smooth ass [__] talking about that
[__] the [__] beautiful ebony sisters
all around him in the middle of the
commercial that [__] that was a good
idea huh that was a good
idea and it was what was funny it
probably was that was not an effective
marketing campaign
on a on on white
adults of that time no but I was I was a
white child and it was effective on me I
was like yeah let me try that I remember
commercial let me try that yeah [__]
Lando drinks that [__] sure it worked
and he's cool as [__] yeah so uh man
grown up white people back then didn't
know [__] just me because [__] our
friend [__] uh [__] Dave drinks it
at the [__] at the uh at the big Tom
drinks it but he's black [__] uh but
uh no when it comes to [__] something
in a can if you're not going to go for
Guinness or something now i' never drink
Bud Light or any of the [__] piss
beers yeah cuz gross I'm going to drink
something like [__]
gtis or uh or [__] M Liquor yeah
honestly if I get beer if we go
someplace like for example that doesn't
have a liquor license and I get beer I
will usually get Killians yeah that's
what I'm saying that's the only good
mass-produced kilan red or if they have
like a good like coffee stout or
something like that I'll get that
Killian is [__] Miller but if they
don't then I get klian cuz that's pretty
decent I'm not a big Beer Drinker I
think that's Miller I think that's
Miller's kind of higher and they're
trying to make yeah cuz Miller Miller
High Life is uh not not good no it's not
good none of the piss beers are any good
they're really not I mean real light
loggers that are [__] garbage tasting
I like micro brew beer and I if it's in
an expensive bottle and it's dark you
know what I mean a dark chocolate
[__] stout or something like that
yeah I'll take that like I said I'm into
coffee Stouts I like that I like those
or um just something real dark and thick
I'll drink that I like I like German
viton beers German white beers they're
really good but they're very [__]
very expensive man they're very
expensive if you don't if you want to if
you you don't have much money you know
what I mean if you want to just
spend the kind of that standard bottle
of beer
price but you want it to be really good
you go for [__] Mal liquor yeah yeah
cuz like I said we got Colt 45 on the
show it was good yeah and we went and
seriously we should have filmed it but
we went to or you went to yeah a a Super
rednecky Liquor Store yeah like not too
far from our house yeah they were making
fun of what I was buying the
girls we're like what it's for the show
it's a taste test yeah they were like
yeah sure I bought that Modello actually
our friend hope that worked at Circle K
she works at that liquor store now we
Modell Modell is now the number one beer
of the United States Modell [__] now
[__] B light got knocked out of the
[__] competition I had Modello
[__] um what was the name of that
[__] it was called uh it was it's a it's
beer and fruit juice mixed together [__]
was [__] great yeah yeah yeah those
were yeah I like those really good we
got I didn't we get like three different
flavors
like mango and
salt yeah we should probably start doing
that again like do like tast test they
got all the holiday [__] coming out now
so it's like they probably got all kind
of fun like gingerbread and peppermint
and all kind of [__] it's a Mexican
drink normally it's just beer and hot
sauce and and over ice what the [__] is
that called it's right on the it's right
on the tip of my michelada melada
michelada I knew i' think of it in a
second but um Modello makes fruit
michelada [__] great tropical fruit
michelada is [__] great
if we couldn't get that though I'd get
[__] some kind of malt liquor I tried
to get uh what was the one [__] bull
no Bulldog I think it was called Bulldog
it was the one the red and black can
yeah yeah but they don't make it anymore
I think it's called Bulldog I don't
remember I was trying to look for all
the old ones I remember from the 90s
they're not around they only had Colt 45
high gravity that sh was high gravity I
love that it was called high gravity
that made me laugh uh side quest Ser
said holy [__] I went and got a tarot
reading and came back and you're still
going yeah yeah Bryce says Stella Stella
is my favorite beer uh side quest hero
says Stella's good I don't remember if
I've ever had Stell Stellar or not Red
Dog I think you're right red dog is what
it's called red dog that's right that's
right like I said I'm not a huge beer
fan yeah if they have anything that's
like kind of coffee or I like pumpkin
alses too which you know that's very
basic [__] of me but I do kind of like
those yeah we have people in Europe that
think oh American Beer [__] sucks
because they're thinking of [__] Bud
Light Bud Light doeser that's the
[__] bottom of the barrel [__]
cheat [__] we have Micro Brewery we
don't like that [__] we have microed
beers
here you can get good beer here you can
get good beer here [__] any anything
to rival European beer you can get it
but the thing about it is that a lot of
them like you said are micro breweries
and some of them you can't get them well
one they're expensive and you can't get
them regularly and you can't get them
all over the country like some of them
are Regional they're local yeah so
that's another problem but yeah you go
to any decent liquor store you can find
all kind of good [__] the best of the
cheap ones I think is
Yingling Yingling yeah I'll drink a
Yingling that's all [__] really good
Yingling or Killian like I said those
are kind of my go-tos if that's all
that's available yeah Yingling is kind
of like America's oldest brewery that's
somewhere up north and the weird thing
about I don't know about nowadays but I
don't think you can get them west of the
Mississippi I got Yingling at I got
Yingling one time at um
Walmart yeah well you can get get it
here but like they don't sell it out
West for whatever reason okay or they
didn't used to because I remember my
sister used to be um she used to live in
Denver and she was married to a guy
they're not married anymore she used to
be married to a guy who was really into
yland because he was from Philly and um
every time they would come to Florida
like to visit his family they would get
like a whole case of Yingling because he
couldn't get it there for whatever
reason they sold other beers there I
don't but for whatever reason Yingling
they didn't sell it like um west of the
Mississippi River so he would always
like stock up when he was in Florida and
then take it back to take it back to
Denver which is really weird victure
said we have it in Texas now so okay so
maybe they are selling it now this was
like several years ago Y yinling is good
quality beer yeah I do like Ying I
forgot about that it comes in different
flavors I like the black and tan that's
real good you take that black and tan
and mix it 50/50 with like hard cider
like Angry Orchard or something and you
[__] it's great yeah yeah I do like
that yeah that's what we would always
get if we'd go to like Wills Pub or yeah
what's that other place what's the place
they used to have Uber Bon uh Falcon the
Falcon that's got that's got our boy
girlfriend working there goth
girl man we haven't been there in a long
time I didn't even realize that was
still there it's a tiny tiny place but
it's super cool yeah they're playing
music there and everything we got it's a
long drive from here that's the problem
it is yeah it is kind of a long drive
just for that you know what I mean
that's like a weekday Drake you don't
want to go there on the weekends yeah
weekends you want to go to [__] well
I want to go somewhere I can dance and
that place is not really big that's just
like a bar but it's you go to on a
Thursday it's a cool bar and they do
have bands sometimes yeah but it's tiny
tiny yeah like you can probably only fit
50 people in there maybe okay it's
starting to get late we're going to shut
this down all right we got to shut the
show down because it's getting late
we've been on for three hours three
hours yeah so hopefully you guys enjoyed
the show thanks very much for all your
super chats and HKS thanks for hanging
out with us on this Wednesday evening
did commercial right yes I did at the
beginning remember okay yeah yeah he
remembers all right so uh we'll be back
as always on Friday night for our
Sidetrack show um which much like this
show except we don't actually have a
topic we just talk about whatever the
[__] we want to so that one's always fun
because we always like get kind of drunk
and talk about whatever if you're new
here so yeah so come back on Friday
night at 7 30 EST for our Sidetrack show
and we hope to see you guys all then and
we will see you then hopefully good
night